okay we have all our jurors
michelle horn ready to proceed yesterday
all right this is state versus michael
albariston indictment
19-12-0-9-9-9-i may have appearances of
counsel they please the court
christopher sheldon for the state thank
you good morning your honor alexander
ben on behalf of the states
and christopher dining are also on
behalf of this embarrassing good morning
everyone please be seated hope everyone
had a nice weekend
record will reflect mr barristone as
present dressed in street attire
including a shirt and tie
all right if we're ready to proceed
let's call the jurors in please
who's your witness mr shalhorn detective
jason
and you'll have another witness after
that
yes detectives
uh
first
so
good morning everyone please be seated
hope everyone had a nice weekend
we are ready to proceed with the state's
case mr shellhorn good morning please
call your next witness
thank your honor the state calls
detective jason gould
all right detective jason gould to the
stand
[Music]
morning detective can you please place
your left hand on the bible raise your
right hand listen to the oath as my core
clerk administers it please do you so in
the presence of almighty god that the
testimony considers court regarding this
matter shall be the truth the whole
truth and nothing but the truth yes
please state your name and spell your
last name for the record jason gould
g-o-u-l-d thank you
a good detective please have a seat keep
your voice up nice and loud so all the
members of the jury including those in
the gallery can hear if you don't
understand a question please indicate
that i'll have council rephrase okay go
ahead mr shellhorn thank you
good morning detective good morning can
you please introduce yourself again to
the jury and tell them where you work
sure my name is jason gould i'm a
detective at the morris county
prosecutor's office
what is your current rank and assignment
i'm a detective i'm assigned to the
specialized crimes division have you
ever been assigned to any other units
with the prosecutor's office yes what
units the major crimes unit and general
investigations unit
do you have any prior law enforcement
experience before you joined the
prosecutor's office yes i do i was a
police officer in randolph
the randolph police department for
approximately 11 years
i want to take your attention to august
7th of 2019 were you working for the
prosecutor's office at that time yes sir
what unit were you assigned to at that
time the major crimes unit can you
briefly explain to the jury what the
responsibilities generally are of the
major crime scene yes we respond to
or investigate death investigations
homicide shootings suspicious death
suicide
drug induced deaths fatal
motor vehicle crashes
bank robberies aggravated assaults
at the time you were assigned to the
major crimes unit in august of 2019 what
was the typical dress or uniform
uh similar to how i'm dressed today suit
and tie
how does the major crimes unit from the
prosecutor's office typically become
involved in an investigation
generally we are notified by a local
municipality
and or the state police
through the morris county communications
center if they're looking to speak with
an alcohol detective of the unit
now specifically on august 7 2019 at
approximately 2 25 that afternoon do you
remember where you were
yes i was in the
major crimes
um squadron at the morris county
prosecutor's office who was the
supervisor of the unit at the time uh
sergeant michael poskus
at approximately that time on that day
did you become made aware of uh an
incident in washington township yes
can you very very basically describe
your understanding of the nature of the
incident we advised that there was an
active shooter and there was one person
who received
two gunshot wounds
at some point were you given a an
assignment respective to that
investigation yes sir what were you
assigned to do i was asked to respond to
the morristown medical center
do you know if any other members of the
major crimes unit were given different
responsibilities yes they were who made
that decision sergeant michael poskus
are you aware of what other agencies
were involved in the investigation yes
the washington township police
department
and
the morris county sheriff's office
at some point did you respond to the
morristown medical center yes sir do you
recall approximately what time you
arrived there i arrived at approximately
3 40 p.m
when you arrived where did you go
to the icu intensive care unit
were there any other law enforcement
officers related to this investigation
at the hospital at that time
yes sir there was
sergeant
burns of the washington township police
department
and
detective kovacs from the morris county
sheriff's office crime scene
investigations and you recall generally
how they were dressed
they were both in uniform
are you aware when you arrived whether
any individuals were already at the
hospital
yes
upon arrival i was advised that the
victim of the shooting
lauren karenick was
in intensive care
approximately how long were you at the
hospital overall on august 7 2019
approximately six hours
now at some point did any other
individual involved in this incident
arrive at the hospital yes who was that
uh michael garrison
and do you see michael barrasson in
court today yes i do could you identify
that person by an article clothing away
yes he's seated at the table uh wearing
a white shirt
yellow tie has
glasses on and
long
gray hair
let's stipulate he's identified my
client yes he has identifying the
defendant
michael barissone for the record are you
aware of how the defendant arrived to
the hospital
yes he was transported from
the scene in an ambulance
and do you know approximately what time
he arrived at the hospital
um he arrived at approximately
3 40
pm from what i
recall
do you recall if there were any law
enforcement officers with them
yes
do you remember who that was yeah so
there was patrolman barnes
and patrolman hensley
of the washington township police
department do you recall how they were
dressed
in full uniform
do you know where the defendant was
taken in the hospital he was also taking
icu
was the area where the defendant was
taken nearby where uh lauren canara was
yes it was can you describe that to the
jury yes uh mr barrison was taken to a
room uh
directly
next to the room where mrs karanick was
and where were you posted
uh in the hallway
what was your purpose in being there
just to get uh updates on both patients
to be able to relay back to my chain of
command
was the area where the defendant was
being treated open or closed
uh
closed
was it closed with a door or something
else more or less a curtain
were you able to see the defendant in
the room at all yes can you describe his
appearance for the jury
yes um he came in wearing um
no shirt
and a pair of
shorts
he had visible
injury to his
to his face
to his left arm
left abdomen
and where was he in the room
he was in a hospital bed
was he restrained or handcuffed at all
in the room yes he was which uh was it
uh he was handcuffed
were medical personnel in the room at
all yes and did you observe generally
what they were doing yes what was that
uh initially just assessing him for his
injuries
and then subsequently treating him for
his injuries
during the time that the defendant was
in the room did you overhear him make
any statements yes i did
did you overhear the statements or do
you recall the statements verbatim or
generally what the nature of the
statements were general nature
can you tell the jury what the
statements that you overheard him making
in a general sense where yes i heard him
make two statements one to the effect of
they destroyed my life in the last six
months
followed
approximately one minute later by i had
a good life they took it all away i'm
sorry it happened
do you recall how many times the
approximate number of times that he said
each statement
once did you record those statements in
any way
yes i noted them uh on my field notes
did you later add that into your formal
police report yes sir
how far would you estimate that you were
from the defendant at the time you
overheard those statements
approximately 10 to 15 feet
did he make those statements in response
to any questioning by you no sir did he
make them in response to questioning by
other law enforcement officers no sir
did he make him in response to any
medical personnel no sir
what was his appearance or demeanor
during the time you observed him making
this event
he was cooperative uh was expressing
verbally that he was in pain
did you have any issues understanding
the words or language that he used no
are you aware during the time that he
was being treated by medical personnel
of whether they were administering any
medications to him
prior to the hospital i can't i can't
say that
at the time that you were observing him
getting treated in the room at the
hospital yes he was given medications
for pain
do you have any direct knowledge of what
was administered
yes just prior to making the initial
statement which i just testified to he
was given a dose of fentanyl
do you know that because you saw that or
how do you know i observe that and then
ask subsequently ask the hospital staff
and then after he was also
continuing to
verbally express that he was still in
pain
and he was given subsequent
doses of what i was advised was
fentanyl and ketamine
so you don't know that that was what was
administered that's just what you were
told yes
were you present when the defendant was
photographed and processed by csi
detectives yes i was
you recall approximately what time that
was it was approximately 9 pm
did the csi detectives take possession
of any uh items that came to the
hospital with the defendant yes and did
they do that while you were still in the
vicinity or the area
yes do you recall in general what those
items were
just from right they just stuck clothing
did they have permission to approach
yes
just for the record i'm going to show
the detective what's been marked with
s193
detective gould i think there are some
gloves there if you need them
but you could just open that bag
and look inside and
indicate whether or not that appears to
be
some of the items that were recovered at
the time you were at the hospital
yes
193 will be admitted into evidence
detective you could just remove that
item and show it to the jury
tell the jury what it is and show it to
the jury
uh part of a
waste belt
another uh
it's the other part of the belt
and then khaki
i guess torn khaki
pants
and are you aware of whether those were
cut in your presence or
outside your presence outside
anything else you could just ask the
jury in the back if they need the
detective to
hold those up again members of the jury
were you able to see the clothes
i see everyone nodding their head yes
thank you
[Music]
thank you
you indicated that you were at the
hospital for approximately six hours
yes sir
when you left the hospital where did you
go
i left the morristown medical center and
responded to the scene of the incident
and was that a 411 west 411 west mill
road in washington
morris county when you got there did you
have any assignment at that location
yes sergeant puskas requested that i
assist detective corporal mangia freda
of the morris county sheriff's office
crime scene investigations
to
conduct a search
of a vehicle at the scene
do you recall what type of vehicle that
was this was a
silver and colored dodge ram pickup
four-door do you recall approximately
where that was parked
near the
residence that the victim was residing
in
judge no further questions thank you
close examination
detective
you previously testified in the hearing
uh
with regards to
this case correct yes sir
and were you giving a transcript of that
previous hearing uh prior to your
testimony today yes sir
and you refused that with the prosecutor
correct
yes sir
uh isn't it the fact that in that prior
hearing
you testified that the fentanyl was
given after the statements correct
initially yes
and then
and correct me if i'm wrong when i
brought out your notes
it's clear from your notes
that the fentanyl was administered prior
to any statements correct
a dose of fentanyl was
given prior to the initial statement yes
and when you say eight dose
a hundred
milligrams of fentanyl was injected into
michael barason prior to any statements
correct
yes sir
you've been
in law enforcement for how many years
total
uh in january i began 16 sir
and
would you agree with me that it's
important
when
drafting an official
drifting a official report
concerning an incident
that it has to be accurate
and contain
as much detail as possible
yes sir
now
when
you got to the hospital
there were already numerous other
officers correct
there there was law enforcement there
yes
and was
were people talking about uh this case
and what had happened back at uh michael
barrasson's farm
yes that was
something that was spoken about
now michael barrasson was taken into a
room uh you you've been shown the pants
which have been admitted into evidence
was he wearing any shirt
not that i recall
now
those pants that you
show to the jury
are there any holes
in the groin area
between michael barisson's where michael
barisson's legs would uh
be
i would have to inspect them again sir
can you do that yes
[Music]
so
there are two tears in the pants that i
see
and close to the groin would those two
tears be approximately work my hand is
on my leg approximately sir
and for the record i'm
pointing to the upper groin area
now
you indicated on direct when you saw
michael barristone that
you observed numerous injuries correct
yes sir
for instance you observed his
his left arm correct yes sir
and would you describe it as uh deformed
yes sir
uh incapable of of holding an item at
that point based on your observations
correct
i couldn't say definitively sir but yes
he had an injury to his left arm a
severe injury based on your observations
correct
significant yes
now he also had injuries to his face
correct yes sir
um were both his eyes blackened yes sir
did he have a gash over his right eye
yes sir uh were both his ears
swollen
and and uh cut up yes sir
did one look like it was almost
cauliflowered swollen uh closed
they did appear to have swelling yes
did you see uh an injury to his side
area
uh yes like an abrasion
and abrasion or
numerous
abrasion abrasions
abrasion sir
now
when you got there michael barrasson was
being
treated by a number of paramedics
correct
he was treated during the transport
okay and he was treated by
a kimberly
head and a daniel vitale correct yes sir
now
when you were there
did you hear michael barrisson
at any point in time
say that he didn't recall the event that
had just taken place no sir not
specifically
i'm going to show you what has been more
d10f
and ask you to take a look at this
i'm aware of you
judge while the detectives are viewing
that can we be heard of sidebar sure
production's overwhelmed
do you recall michael barristone saying
that he didn't recall what happened
i understand that's in my notes sir but
that wasn't something that i heard him
say directly
in speaking with the officers i believe
that's where that
note came from
but not from anything i heard him say
directly
how many officers told you
that michael barriston hidden that's
that's here say mister can you number
judge
well it's still hearsay the witness said
he didn't hear it himself it came from
other people so
just asking how many people
regarding that
well
did you hear multiple officers did you
speak to multiple officers about things
mr barrasso may have said
i spoke to officers judge about what
took place at the scene how many
officers just tell me how many officers
did you speak to about what happened at
the scene from washington township at
this point uh there were three officers
there
now
you didn't put that in your report
correct
no sir
now
prior to any statement that you did here
would you agree with me that michael
barrasson was in excruciating
pain
he was expressing the fact that he was
experiencing pain yes sir
and
what if anything did you observe with
regards his demeanor
with regards to being in pain
aside from the again he was verbally
expressing that he was looking for
something to
treat the pain he was experiencing when
when someone touched him or or
came near his his arm you know did he
make facial expressions did he indicate
from his expressions or his his actions
that he was in
serious pain from his expressions yes
you could see that he was experiencing
pain
now
would you agree with me
that you took
detailed copious notes correct
yes sir
and
when i say detailed and copious
you make specific references with
regards to
exact times
when things
happen were you observed correct
yes
you put the exact time he arrived at the
hospital 15 20 correct
uh that was my arrival sir are you
reading from his notes or refreshing his
memory
it's like it looked like you were
reading his notes so if you if you want
to refresh his memory you can do so
you put in an exact time when michael
barrasson got there correct yes sir
exact times when other officers from
washington township arrived correct
yes
you
literally
wrote down every detail
that you observed
contemporaneous with
what you observed correct
yes sir
now
how many days did you write your
official report after the incident
my report was drafted the next day sir
when was it
when's the date of the report
are you asking the date on the actual
report the date on the actual report
uh
that's the date that my supervisors
approve it not the date that i completed
sir
is there anything on the report that
indicates the date that you completed it
on the report sir enough
anywhere
is there anything to indicate
that
you did the report prior to
october 23rd
against her
date on the report is the date it was
approved by a supervisor not the date
that i completed it
or not the date that i typed it if
that's what you're on did you make a
rough draft of that report
yes there was a draft of the report
before it's approved
okay and where is that rough draft of
the report that you made
earlier than the date that was approved
it's typed on that report
through our infoshare system
and when you say
a supervisor had to approve it
did
someone from your office go over
the report
to make sure that it was
accurate and correct
a supervisor has to approve it yes sir
and what are they approving
i can't testify as to what they're
looking at in their reports are what's
the purpose of the supervisor to your
knowledge
reviewing your report before it's
submitted
to review what is contained within the
report
and
has the supervisor ever
told you to take something out or
include something prior to it being
submitted as a an official report
it's a pencil it has happened though
correct
or something is amended in the report
yes
yes
now
michael barrasson
and correct me if i'm wrong
at 1356
made the first statement that you
testified to correct
that's not correct sir it's a clerical
error
now when you say clerical hour whose
clerical error is it
it's my report sir
did your supervisor pick up that
clerical error and talk to you about it
i can't testify as to what
they did or didn't do sir
what time did michaels barristone make
this statement that you just talked to
that would be my life in the last six
months that
would have been at 15 56 hours
so
3 56
pm
so your report is inaccurate correct
that time should be 13 15 56 sir
and
when did you realize that there was a
clerical error in your report
after it was approved sir
and at any point in time did you
seek to address that that issue
and change the report to reflect the
accurate time
no sir
is there anything else in that report
that's inaccurate no sir
now
before the first statement
you've testified that michael barrasson
received
fentanyl correct yes sir
and he also received fentanyl academy
after that statement correct yes sir and
soon after that isn't it the fact that
soon after what you mentioned two things
fentanyl and then fentanyl and ketamine
so specify what you're talking about
please
soon after the second injections of
fentanyl and ketamine
he basically passed out correct
yes he became
it appeared like in a state of sleep
now
when you first saw michael barrasson was
he incoherent
i wouldn't describe this that no sir
now you testify to a second statement
correct
yes sir
and
you testified
correctly from wrong
that at some point in time
michael barrasson said
he was sorry
correct yes sir
and you put that in the official report
correct yes sir
now
can you tell me
whether or not
anywhere in the notes that you took on
the day in question
contemporary
contemporaries with
what was going on
did you include in your notes anywhere
that he said
i'm sorry
after that note of that statement no sir
i'm referring to the notes that you took
at the time in the
incident
correct yes
in in my notes
after that no it's not in my notes
when you say after that
i want to make sure i'm clear on this
point in your official notes
isn't it the fact
that nowhere
is there any reference to michael
barristone saying the words i'm sorry
in my notes no it is not sir
but the other two specific statements
word for word
are included correct
yes in my notes
and in your official report yes sir
now
you indicated you were standing outside
of the area where michael barrasson was
was was being treated
you don't recall the exact words of what
he said correct
correct no the statements were made in
effect they weren't made directly to me
sir
was he talking to anyone or was just
talking to himself he was speaking out
loud sir
was he
talking to anyone based on your
observations
at which point sir at any point
with respect to him making any
statements
the statements the statements that
you've testified to was he
talking
just for clarification maybe a little
confusion
whether he's
this witness may not know whether he was
speaking directly to someone
when he was uttering those statements
perhaps the better question is was there
anyone present around his bedside was he
being treated at that time when he spoke
just so we avoid
confusion about these people destroying
his life they were all made while he was
in his
hospital bed
and were people around him yes or a
medical person out there sir
were they asking him questions or
was he just making these statements
without any questions
they weren't prompted by any specific
question by anyone sir
certainly
i'm going to show you a number of
photographs
eight d 800-52
to d
800-75
and ask you just to
review these
valencia would you still like these
pants out or would you know what those
guys
put them away thanks
thanks
so
thank you you're welcome um i'm just
going to ask you to take a look at these
photographs
just up here don't let anyone else see
them
maybe put them face down when you're
done okay
would you like me to go through them yep
the paper clips are just copies there's
copies
get a chance to take a look at those yes
sir are they
consistent with your observations of
the injuries that michael barristone
suffered on that day yes sir
now
you testified that
that one statement
in your notes that
you didn't include in your report
was
something someone else told you correct
which statement specifically sir
the statement with regards to i don't
recall
yes sir
in your three pages of notes or four
pages of notes
is there any other reference
to anything that anyone else told you
during
your time
i'd have to review them sir can you
i mean on the first page don't don't
don't read it out loud if it's from
someone else
what someone else told you it's hearsay
but there is some reference about
something that someone else told you
just answer yes or no yes sir all right
what's the next question i'm done
any redirect judge could i have a
breakout room to show the detective his
report
sure
not to publish it just to show it to him
based on yes
judge while that's pulling up for the
record this is uh s 149 for
identification okay
detective while that's pulling up you
were asked some questions about times
that were in your notes in your reports
yes sir and i think you testified on
direct examination
about the approximate time that you
arrived to
morristown medical center yes sir
i'm going to direct you to
what should be coming up in front of you
as s149 do you see that yes
is that a
copy of the report that you were
discussing earlier on cross examination
yes sir
and if we look on page one
in the narrative section
does that indicate approximately what
time you arrived at morristown medical
center yes sir what time is that
approximately 15 20 hours and for those
of the jury who are not familiar with 24
hour time what time is uh 15 20 in 12
hour time
3 20 pm
now scrolling down to page two of that
report you were asked questions about
the times that you overheard
the defendant make certain statements
yes sir
and does it indicate on that page
approximately halfway down when you
observe or overheard him make those
statements yes sir what is the first
time that's typed there in your report
it's typed uh 13 56 hours which would be
approximately which would be what time
in 12 hours uh 1 56 p.m
what time was the second statement typed
in
15 57 hours which is what time 3 57 so
is it fair to say that you did not hear
the defendant make a statement at 1 56
that afternoon before you arrive to the
hospital that's correct sir and that's
what you're indicating with a clerical
error or a mistake in your in your
record
go for the question
you may step down thank you thank you
mr shalhorn yes your honor the state
will call
officer jason hensley officer jason
hensley please
yeah
hold on one sec uh miss radler is the
person from i.t here
i'm just having some computer issues i
need i.t to take a look at it
all right let's swear in the witness
while we wait
left hand on the bible thank you raise
your right hand do you swing the
presence of almighty god that the
testimony of to this court regarding
this matter shall be the truth the whole
truth and nothing but the truth i do
please state your name must by your last
name for the record jason hensley
h-e-n-s-l-e-y thank you
have a seat go ahead we'll begin and
then when it gets here we'll just take a
quick a quick uh hopefully five minute
break
officer hensley can you please introduce
yourself to the jury and tell them where
you work
officer jason hensley i work with the
washington township police department
and approximately how long have you
worked for the washington township
police department approximately four and
a half years
what's your current rank and assignment
patrol
and patrol officer
do you have any prior law enforcement
experience before joining the washington
township police department i worked for
two years in manhattan township police
department
direct your attention to august 7 2019
were you working for the washington
township police department at that time
yes what were you doing on the afternoon
of august 7 2019. i was working a third
party detail can you explain to the jury
generally what that means
construction companies and outside
contractors hire us to do traffic
control
in their work zones when they're working
in town
do you recall what the nature of the
third party
assignment was on that date yes we're
working with a tree trimming company
do you recall the approximate area where
that was happening uh westmoreland
how were you dressed on that day
i was wearing our class c uniform
and what uniform are you wearing today
important this is a class b uniform what
would be the difference between a class
b uniform and a class c uniform
there's nothing different except the
badge and they are embroidered there's a
patch on each arm and that day in
question i was wearing a short sleeve
version of that
uniform directing your attention
just hold on for one second
[Music]
um
um
go ahead mr shellhorn your honor
is this supposed to be
no mr blankens can you take that back
please
thank you officer
thanks
officer hensley uh
i apologize if i already asked you this
question but i just want to make sure
that the record is clear
do you recall where you were working
that or the general area where you were
working that third party detail at
approximately 2 15 the afternoon of
august 7th 2019. at that point we were
on a lunch break and we were right
outside our town line in industrial area
um we were in the parking lot at that
point were there any other washington
township police officers there with you
yes who was that detective pimer
and i'm just going to ask you to keep
your voice up a little bit if you uh can
that microcode doesn't actually amplify
okay
so just to make sure that the jury in
the back behind you can hear you yes uh
do you recall how detective heimer was
dressed he was dressed in the same
fashion i was wearing a class c uniform
at that time approximately 2 15 that
afternoon do you recall receiving a
dispatch over your radio yes do you
recall the address where that dispatch
was for yes what was the the address 411
west mill road what was the general
nature of the dispatch active shooter
what did you do after receiving that
dispatch
i
confirmed that with detective heimer
what the nature of the call was
and he had a ballistic vest with him at
that point so he began to respond
what did you do
i looked in my trunk and found a
ballistic vest and i responded as
well had you ever been to the property
of 411 west mill road before yes can you
describe for the jury in a general sense
the layout of the property
there's a farmhouse several hundred
several hundred feet off of west mill
road
um on the left side of the driveway
going in and as you proceed back into
the
rear of the property there's a horse
equestrian facility
are you ever able to see the equestrian
facility from the road
maybe the roof if i recall correctly
when you
uh proceeded to 411 west mill road in
response to that dispatch at some point
did you pull into the driveway yes were
there any other police officers already
on scene detective heimer and officer
wardenberg
do you recall uh if you saw where
their vehicles were parked
they were parked in the driveway
um
the portion of the driveway that goes
all the way back to the horse farm
where were they parked in relation to
the area of the farmhouse
right next to it oh if you're driving in
it'd be to the right of the farmhouse
upon pulling into the driveway and
seeing their cars there could you see
them
no
um what did you do when you saw their
cars there i put my car in park and got
out and immediately heard commotion
coming from the rear of the residence
where did you go
that's why i went to the rear of the
residence what did you first see when
you arrived in the area of the back of
the residence
i saw officer
wardenberg and detective hymer and three
unidentified parties
do you recall the position of the
unidentified parties
officer heimer was standing over
one
um there was a gravel pile in that piece
that area and officer wurttenberg was
with another and there was a female that
was laying next to um
the stairs where officer heimer was
standing over top of the male subject
during the course of uh the
investigation as it evolved did you come
to learn who the identities of those
people were yes did you learn who the
female was yes who is that lauren kenner
did you come to learn the identity of
the person that detective heimer was
standing by yes who was that michael
barrasso do you see michael barrasson in
court today yes can you identify him by
an article of clothing that he's wearing
he's wearing a white shirt yellow tie
received at the council's table on
identifying the defendant for the record
and you indicated that uh officer
wortenberg was with another male yes did
you come to learn who that male was yes
who is that robert goodwin
where did you go first when you saw this
to
officer heimer's position and what did
you do when you got there i began
assessing the victim
or the patient who was on the ground at
the time what were your initial
observations of ms kenner
she was pale um and had a little bit of
blood on her folks
judgment permission to display s 389 to
the jury it is already
yes
right s 389 is being displayed on the
screens the monitors to the members of
the jury go ahead mr shellhorn officer
hensley can you please tell the jury the
approximate area where you parked your
patrol car when you got into the
property
right in the area that says driveway
on the
on the diagram right in that general
area
and when you proceeded to the area of
the rear of the farmhouse
can you describe the area where you saw
officer wurttenberg and mr goodwin
approximately
between the rear steps and the part
that's labeled gravel pile
do you see the area where you saw
detective hymer and uh the defending yes
can you describe for the jury the
approximate area where you observe the
two of them
it says back door
in the bottom right corner of the
portion that says house um they were
right off the stairs there
and uh where where did you observe ms
camera
if you're looking at it
from right there it'd be to the left of
the rear stairs between the bush and the
rear stairs
now you indicated that you first went
over to the area where detective hymer
and the defendant were and miss canara
yes
uh
and you indicated that you made some
observations of miss canorack yes what
did you do at that point i began to
remove her clothes to see where
she
the wounds were and what the nature of
them were did you identify an
approximate area on her body where there
were ones the upper left portion of her
chest did you see how many there were
uh it appeared there were two bullet
foods
and could you uh
describe what you saw as you removed
some of the clothing that was in the way
and you saw those wounds in that area
there was a little bit of blood um
and what looked like to puncture or
bullet wounds
what did you do next
i began to try and hold pressure on the
two wounds um there was a lot going on
there but as from what i had that's the
only thing i could uh medically do at
that point
at some point did other officers arrive
to the scene yes
several washington township officers
arrived did they bring anything with
them they brought various medical gear
what did they do when they got on scene
i gave over
patient care to them because i wasn't
a certified emt at that point so they
had better knowledge of what miss
cantarak needed medically
versus me
after turning over care for ms canarac
to the other officers what did you do
next
i
took custody of mr barrison
at the time you took custody of him was
he restrained or handcuffed in any way
he was handcuffed
were there any other officers with you
when you took custody of him no
when you took custody of him did you
tell him anything
i'd advise him of his miranda rights
at some point during my interaction with
him yes can you explain to the members
of the jury what miranda rights are
miranda rights are given to anybody
who's in custody or who may or may not
be subject to an investigation
why did you give him uh or advise him of
his miranda rights at that time due to
the nature of the call
we're still sorting stuff out how did
you advise him of those rights
i carry a card on me every time i'm
working and i read them verbatim off a
card so that they're systematic and the
same every time
do you recall and i can refer you back
to s 389 do you recall the approximate
area where you were when you advised the
defendant of those rights
somewhere between the rear steps until
he was seated against an enclosed
trailer which is depicted in this
diagram
can you describe the general area where
that
um there's a vehicle that's
marked fl req
one f seven q ue
it was at some point in the gravel area
directly in front of that
after you advised him of those rights uh
did he acknowledge them in any way yes
he verbally acknowledged that he
understood the rights and you recall
specifically what he said in
acknowledging what you had just told him
no i don't recall i know it was a verbal
acknowledgement
did you ask him any questions after
administering those rights to him
yes just medical questions trying to
ascertain uh if you had any further
injuries that i couldn't see
were you able to observe if you did have
any injuries it appeared he had a
laceration on his head um his head and
face were covered in blood
you indicated that after uh at some
point after you took custody of mr
barrissone in the area of the back door
of the residence
uh that you
were with him as he made his way across
the uh
the driveway there yes can you describe
to the jury where he went first
um
i took him away from the immediate area
so
other members of the department can
render aid to mrs canorack
and which was directly in front of that
pick that truck i described before which
is about in the center of that gravel
parking lot behind the rear door
when you were in that area do you recall
was he standing or sitting or something
else
i believe he was kneeling at one point
um i know that i did
search him when he was standing well
how did you search him
so
any anytime we search we're taunting the
academy i mean it's
standardized and systematic you're
searching for any weapons or any
contraband um and that's what i did when
i searched mister so did you uh
pat down or uh touch parts of his body
yes yeah it was a routine pat down um
looking for anything
did you find anything in any of his
pockets yes in his right front pocket of
his pants there was a handgun magazine
judge may i approach the witness yes
officer hensley i'm going to show you
what's been entered into evidence
already as s-178
look at that and determine what that is
[Applause]
there are actually gloves right on the
floor
yes
what is that
that's the handgun magazine i pulled
from mr barrison's right front pants
pocket
when you pulled it out of his pocket
were you able to tell whether there were
bullets in the magazine yes
did you take the bullets out at that
time no what did you do with the
magazine i gave the magazine to sergeant
bigham who was also there helping me pat
down mr barizone at that time and did
you see what he did with the magazine
sergeant bigham secured the magazine in
the rear of if i recall correctly
corporal fellini's the trunk of corporal
fellini's patrol vehicle and
approximately how far away was that
vehicle from where you were with mr
barrison approximately 15 to 20 feet
after locating that in mr barriston's
pocket
and turning it over to to sergeant
pigham to or
i'm sorry i forgot what rank i think it
is sergeant victor sergeant and turning
that over to sergeant bingham uh did you
take the defendant michael barrasson
anywhere else on the property yes he was
moved from that specific area to the
side of an enclosed trailer which is on
the edge of the gravel lot approximately
20
feet from my location
did you see while he was in that area if
he was treated or
examined by any ems personnel he was
i'm going to show you uh what's been
marked as s 250 and entered into
evidence already
what is s 250 a picture of
that's mr parison's clothing and shoes
and is that in the approximate area you
were just describing to the jury where
you saw him receiving medical treatment
yes
were you given any assignments with
respect to uh mr barrissone and his
transport off the property yes what were
you uh instructed to do i was to
accompany
i was instructed to accompany mr bear
zone to morristown medical center
did you do that yes how did he get to
the morrison medical center
i'm not sure if it was a long valley
first aid squad ambulance or an atlantic
ambulance but it wasn't he was in the
back of an ambulance
were there emts or other medical
personnel in the ambulance yes what were
they doing during the course of the the
transport from
long valley to morristown assessing and
treating
mr you recall approximately how long
that transport took
approximately 30 minutes
was he
was mr barriston the defendant uh
restrained or handcuffed while he was in
the back of the ambulance yes
do you recall specifically any of the
medical conversations or the
conversations that he was having with
the medical
personnel they were just talking
speaking medically to him in the sense
of asking him to try and ascertain what
was wrong with him and they were
treating him medically
did you ask him any questions no
during the course of time that the
defendant was in the back of the
ambulance being transported to
morristown
uh did he make any statements that you
do recall yes
were those statements made in response
to any specific questions from the
medical personnel no
can you tell the jury what you recall
over hearing the defendant say
is this real
and i need to wake up
do you recall the approximate number of
times that he made each of those
statements
undetermined but there was it was
multiple several times
did you hear him say those words
verbatim or is that a a summary or just
your recollection of what he said if i
recall my report correctly that were
direct statements that were in
his quote
were those statements recorded
no
were they required to be recorded
no
what was the defendant's appearance or
demeanor during the time that you were
observing him in the uh
in the ambulance appeared robotic
other than in the ambulance i was seated
behind him so i wasn't able to
see his appearance
i mean you see his face no it's on the
back of his head
did you have any issues understanding
the words he was using or the language
he was using no
do you recall when you arrived at
morristown medical center
yes
what happened when you arrived there
mr person was taken out of the ambulance
and brought inside
the hospital and brought to a trauma
room do you recall if there were any
other members of law enforcement at the
hospital already
officer barnes followed me
that i recall he was the only officer
that i directly remember seeing when i
got out of the ambulance
when you went inside did you see other
members of law enforcement
officer barnes um and at some point
uh detective gould was there from the
prosecutor's office
what was your role at the hospital once
you arrived there i was to maintain
contact with mr barristone visually
isn't in a security function
where were you while you were doing that
i was outside the trauma room that mr
barrison was in
do you have any recollection of the
treatment that he received while he was
there no
no further questions for officer hensley
at this time thank you judge
well council cross examination please
good morning officer good morning
now
you were with hamer
when you got the call to respond
detective heimer yes
and uh
[Applause]
he left and you immediately followed
thereafter correct negative
how
long after
did you arrive
uh from hama
approximately one minute after detective
heimer
all right so
detector heimer gets there
do you arrive approximately a minute
after correct approximately yes and and
you immediately have an opportunity to
observe michael barisson correct
immediately in what sensor
you you were right there with cataract
and barista yes when i went to officer
heimer's position yes i immediately
observed him okay and would you describe
michael barisson at that point
uh as
partially conscious
yes
would you describe him as incoherent
i didn't have too much interaction with
him so i
well when you say you didn't have
interaction with him
you miranda's them correct
at that point yes yes i did
and was he
incoherent at that point no
now
you said you used your uh card that you
always used correct yes and again that's
i assume so you don't leave anything out
you
ask the questions verbatim each and
every time correct yes
and your testimony that on day you asked
all the questions on your card correct
yes and and what was michael
barristone's response to each and every
question
at the end
his he verbally acknowledged that i read
him his miranda warnings
what do you mean he verbally
acknowledged
i don't recall if he said yes or i
understand or something of that nature
but he verbally verbally acknowledged
that he understood what i just told him
and and what did he say when
you said
having these rights in mind
to talk to us now
i don't recall
you asked him that question correct yes
and
you have no recollection of of what he
said in response to that specific
question that was on your card it was a
summary of i read everything
and then i asked him if he understood
and then you asked him
having these rights in mind do you wish
to talk to us now correct
i don't recall what his answer was to
that
at that point i wasn't going to ask him
anything investigative
now
when you got there was michael
barristone handcuffed yes
was he handcuffed behind his back
correction correction
he was not handcuffed he was handcuffed
while i was there
was he handcuffed behind his back yes um
did he make any indication to you
when his left arm was put behind his
back in handcuffs that he was in pain
not i did not handcuff him so to me no
while he
strike that while you were there
interacting with him
his hand
were cuffed behind his back correct yes
and
at any point in time
when his hands and both arms were cuffed
behind his back
did he indicate to you that he was in
pain not that i recall
did you
notice anything or observe
him which would indicate to you that he
was in pain no like wincing or
making expressions when when he was
moved one way or another no
now
you rode with them in the hospital up
strike that you rode with them in the
ambulance to the hospital correct yes
and
um
did you see any medical personnel
um inject any
thing into his body
i did not observe that no did michael
barizone at any point in
complaining that he was in pain
not that i'm aware
was he still handcuffed behind his back
if i recall correctly yes
um
based on your observations
before he was put in the ambulance you
made an observation incorrectly if i'm
wrong that his
left arm
could well have been fractured correct
i don't recall that
can quicken things up here
i'm going to refer you to
a sentence in the fourth paragraph of
your official police report
yes
several lacerations and impossible
fractures left on and you were aware of
that
before it was placed in the ambulance
correct it appears so
and did anyone try to
accommodate that fracture when they
secured him in the ambulance to your
knowledge not that i'm aware
when was uh your official report uh done
um i don't know if there's an author
date
if this is accurate then it was on
august 11th
when was it approved by supervisor
it says yes report date august 11th
now what is report date mean
if i could recall that it's when i
authored the report
not what a supervisor
approves your report correct
uh i'm unaware of that i've never
approved the report
this state on your report that says
report date
indicates to you that that's when you
wrote and submitted it correct
it appears that way yes
now
during the transport to the hospital
it's your testimony that
michael barrison repeatedly said
is this real
is that correct
yes
and he said it
how many times
multiple times i can't put a number on
it right so so as he's going to the
hospital he continually says
or says multiple times is this real
is this real
he said it in conjunction in conjunction
with the other statement that had in
quotes there okay the other statement
i need to wake up
i need to wake up
how many times did he say that same
amount of time since the first statement
they were one and the same that he was
saying them one after the other
the same phrase
now
you would
indicate it on direct that you uh you
were familiar or of this location
correct
yes
uh you would responded on august 1st to
an incident correct
yes
and will you agree with me that michael
barisson looked
much different
on the seven than he did on the first
correct and what contact sir
his demeanor
i don't really have a clear picture of
his demeanor right now
and finally
the term that you used to describe him
was robotic correct yes
nothing forever
any redirect
no thank you
you may step down thank you
mr horn
did i believe i have one more witness
but i'm not sure
that he's uh here yet so i know it's a
little bit early uh for our morning
break but
all right um
we'll take our morning break early um
we'll take 20 minutes
who's your next witness
edward david
all right ladies and gentlemen we'll
take our morning break for 20 minutes
thank you
on the record
just wait for the door to close please
okay i'll be seated
the detective just advised me he is on
route i think is here somewhere we're
just trying to get him to the courtroom
how long
okay
all right very good be seated everyone
we're ready to continue with the state's
case mr shellhorn please call your next
witness state calls edward david edward
david to the stand please
hi mr david just remain standing for a
moment place your left hand on the bible
please if you would maybe put your
jacket down raise your right hand my
clerk is going to administer you
do you swing the presence of almighty
god that the testimony gives to this
court regarding this matter shall be the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth my so affirmative please state
your name mr last name for the record
edward david david all right mr david
you can have a seat please keep your
voice up nice and loud that microphone
only records
okay if you don't understand a question
from council please indicate that i'll
have them rephrase so
uh to something you understand and if
you hear me say objection or if you hear
counsel say objection don't answer or
stop answering until the court rules
very good proceed mr shellhorn thank you
mr david can you please introduce
yourself to the jury and tell them what
you do for a living
my name is edward david i am an attorney
i practice law in the state of new
jersey and i've been doing that for 40
years i basically do civil
litigation and um
corporate and commercial transaction
work do you know lauren canaric i do you
know robert goodwin i do
i'm not going to ask you any specifics
about it but did you have involvement
with them arising from a tenancy dispute
in august of 2019. i did
i want to specifically direct your
attention to the afternoon of august 7th
2019 do you recall if you had a phone
call with one or both of them that
afternoon
i do do you recall or can you describe
to the jury of what you recall about how
that phone call began
uh parenthetically it was one of the
wildest phone calls i've ever had in my
entire career what
understood just answer the prosecutor's
question please i will i i thought it
needed some context um
i had been
representing lauren for a little over
24-48 hours in connection with a tenancy
issue that she had
and
i had
called
i guess robert's
cell phone
around 2 15 to 10 something like that
to speak to lauren
i i think i tried her cell phone
just to talk to her she was my client
um but i couldn't get her so i called
robert's cell phone
um
to just give her an update on where we
were in negotiations with uh mr
barrisson's attorney
where
perhaps not specifically but generally
where were you when you made that phone
call
i was in a car
driving on route 280 in in or around
west orange new jersey
do you recall
what area of the state you were coming
from at that time
probably the courthouse in newark that's
my guess going back to my office at that
time
was at either becker farm road or
eisenhower parkway in
roseland
who did you speak with or did the call
go through
yes i the call went through i spoke to
robert
and at some point uh during the course
of that conversation did you end up
speaking with miss canary yes
at that point were you able to hear
anything in the background
yes so so what happened was
if i can explain please do what happened
was uh i had spoken i i called robert
and i said to robert objection
what's the basis for the objection
what he says not what robert goodwin
says
he's saying what what he did
what he's what he said to mr goodwin
over the phone
you're not eliciting what mr goodwin
said are you not at this point no that
would be your site
so just tell us not not what robert
goodwin said in response but just what
what you told uh mr goodwin over the
phone okay
i
basically said to robert can i speak to
lauren
um
and and he put lauren on the phone
and
i start to talk to her i don't recall
specifically how long
it was before i heard her say
oh my god there's barizone
he's got a gun or
something like that and then i heard
what i thought were gunshots
and i said lauren lauren lauren are you
okay
um
he i believe she said something like he
shot me in the heart or the chest
and then i heard the phone drop
and
i was obviously in shock
and
[Music]
i recall
we were disconnected or or i couldn't
hear anything so i disconnected the call
um
i didn't know if it was real or not real
i mean that's a bizarre thing
to encounter when you're
riding in your car just expecting to
speak to your client about a tenancy
um issue anyway
so um
at that point i called her back or i
called rob's cell phone back um
nobody answered
and uh then i pulled over
the car and tried to get a hold of
somebody to tell them what i thought had
happened
you indicated that you thought that you
heard uh
bang or bangs yes you recall
approximately how many bangs you heard
two i recall specifically i heard two
and you recall what happened after
hearing those bangs or
do you recall what you heard after
hearing those things yeah it was oh my
god i've been shot in the chest or
maybe it was i've been shot in the heart
um
and i
i remember just yelling lauren lauren
are you okay okay what's going on
and um
i think that's it
now you said that you uh at that point
wanted to make an attempt to let
somebody know did you call
at that point yeah
i learned something that day
when you are out of a particular area
and you dial 9-1-1 you get the local
emergency person from that cell tower so
i dialed 9-1-1
and i got i think the west orange police
department
and so well that didn't work um because
i said i think there was a shooting
somewhere
in washington township um
and uh they said well we we can't help
you we're the west orange police so i
hung up
um you want me to go through all this
yeah and what did you do next okay so so
then
um
i started thing i pulled over because
now i'm i'm a little flustered um i
pulled over
and i i thought to myself well well
where is
lauren and i knew she was
on the farm i had forgotten mr varazon's
name
and i
called
washington town i googled i pulled out
my phone i googled washington township
uh of course i got the wrong washington
township there were two or three of them
in the state
finally got a hold of
the correct washington township mars
county i believe
and
and i
told them
what i knew they said well which farm i
said you know
i don't know the name of the farm
and uh but i know that there had been
incidents there before and they said oh
the barristone form
i said yes that was it
and
[Music]
they said
i believe they said that
we're aware of something and we're
sending a unit out already
i believe that's what happened
no further questions
cross-examination
mr david
you basically uh
knew lauren cataract for a day prior to
this incident correct a day or two yes
and uh
did did you ever meet with her i did
uh you met with her on the six correct
i recall meeting with her i couldn't
tell you the date
the day before the shooting perhaps i
believe so yes
and is that the first time
that you ever
met with uh lauren cataract
person to person yes
had you talked to her on the phone prior
to that i believe i had
how many times
i don't recall
who
retained you
well lauren was my client but i believe
her father john
made the connection
uh was uh robert goodwin uh a client of
yours
no i don't believe so
on that day on the sixth
were you aware that uh
robert goodwin
tape recorded your entire meeting
on that day i was not aware of that at
the time now
are you aware of that now i am aware of
that now
did the prosecutor give you a copy of
the transcript
of the meeting
on august 6th
the meeting between lauren and i
no
i've never seen it nor do i know
the content of it
now
on the sixth
and correct if i'm wrong it was you
lauren cataract
robert goodwin and warren cataract's
father correct
i don't recall
robert goodwin being there but but if
you say he was i i
wouldn't dispute it it's possible
were you informed
at any point that they were recording
private conversations during that
meeting i'm going to object that this is
beyond the scope of the direct
examination
i
understand was maybe we can come to
sidebar
all right the objections over will go
ahead mr blankes
sir
you had a meeting with lauren cataract
and her father
the day before the shooting correct
yes
and isn't it a fact that during that
meeting
for the first time you were praised
that recordings were being made
of private conversations
no
that is not true
okay what were you appraised of with
regards to
private conversations nothing
let me rephrase that nothing that i
recall
judge
before we get into this can we remember
the sidebar again sure
unfortunately
i'm going to ask you to step into the
jury room i do have to conduct what's
called the 104 hearing which is a
hearing with the attorneys and the
witness outside of your presence we
haven't had one yet i've tried to handle
everything at sidebar so we don't waste
time but this this hearing um has to
take place now so just going to the jury
room hopefully i'll keep it as short as
i can it shouldn't be too long thank you
come back in
all right mr uh mr david uh the court
decided based on
miss raddler are the jurors coming in
all right thank you love your cup
thank you it's masters week your golfer
tiger gonna play or no i don't know i
hope so you do
not since hogan
i don't think he'd win but i think if
he's
it would be as big as his win two years
ago three or whatever
this is freshwater by the way
so is that fresh water
yes it is yes thank you just be careful
when you pour it it comes out quickly
you may want to get it yeah i've seen
this before
tell you it's a very strange experience
being here
i can imagine
dirty answering
all right be seated ladies and gentlemen
sorry for the delay i did conduct that
104 hearing with regard to the evidence
and accord to determine that the
evidence was not admissible
go ahead mr blancas
mr david
before we broke you indicated that
you have no recollection of discussing
lawrence cataract tape recording michael
barriston for others during your meeting
correct that's correct
now
you called 9-1-1 correct i did
you gave a statement to the morris
county prosecutor's office
on september 16 2019 do you recall that
i did
and
can i assume that you reviewed that with
the prosecutor no you cannot assume that
did you get a copy of it i did not
now
after you heard whatever you heard
on the telephone
did you make notes
of that conversation
well after the fact i was in a car when
it happened
so i did not take notes and
i didn't get back to my office till
later that day
and can i assume that later that day
after going through something like this
as a lawyer you wrote down everything
that you remembered
in case someone would want to question
you about this i know i did it i can't
tell you when
you can't tell me whether it was the
same day or some days after correct
it was within i might guess it and his
pure guess within 24 hours maybe 36
hours okay something i wouldn't forget
i mean
the whole thing lasted a minute or two
okay well
our conversation understand was was
pretty one-sided and it happened over
the course of 10 or 15 seconds there
wasn't much to remember but i remember
writing down everything she said
everything i i could remember
so within 24 hours your best estimate
you write down everything that you
specifically recall with regards to this
conversation correct
yes
did you give those
notes
to the prosecutor's office
i did
do you recall telling the prosecutor's
office in your official statement that
you destroyed
the original notes
no but i likely did
well i'm certain i did okay didn't you
just say
you gave those original notes to the
morris county prosecutor's office
no you just said that and i agreed
if you'd allow me to rephrase it i gave
them a copy of the notes the originals
understand my office is a green office i
don't keep
hard copies of anything as soon as i
have a document even one that i've
prepared i scan it into the computer
and destroy it
i don't have the capacity to keep 40
years of records
in an office so i do not keep an
original of anything
so
that is for all intents and purposes as
the courts of this state have recognized
appropriate
i'm going to show you
d1200d okay
do you recognize that i do
are these
notes
that you
drafted regarding this incident they are
are these the notes you just testified
you put down
approximately 24 hours or so after the
incident
yes
but i signed it apparently much later
when did you sign it
apparently much later
when did you sign it it is dated
september 16 2019. does that refresh
your recollection that you signed it on
on that day in september i just said i
did
but there's a reason for that well
if you'd like me to explain it i'm happy
to do that okay
what day did you give your statement to
the prosecutor's office don't recall
i show you
a copy of your statement d
1200 c
and ask you if this refreshes your
recollection as to when
you talk to the prosecutor regarding
this
specific instance yes
okay and what day did you talk to the
prosecutor's office
september
2019 and that's why i signed it this day
because i sent this to them i assume on
this date
but i scanned it into my computer and i
could probably dig up the date of the
scan
at or around the time that i wrote it
because that is what i do 100
of the time
i take notes i scan it into my computer
i didn't think i had to date the notes
but when i spoke to the prosecutor's
office and they wanted a copy of it i
signed it i dated it
and i put the time
thank you
sure
that's what i recall anyway
now
prior to this incident you had
a number of conversations with michael
barrasson's lawyer stephen tarshish
correct prior to when
prior to the shooting
yes and
was it your impression that
um
he and you were in the process of
working out lauren cataract leaving the
property
we were working out a settlement of the
the
dispute
one of the issues that we needed to
resolve was if and when lauren would
leave the property yeah
you also mentioned something about
facebook posts
prior to that meeting had you received
some of warren cataract's facebook posts
did you again object that this is beyond
the scope of the direct examination
it is somewhat beyond the scope mr
blancas
all right
now on the day of the
incident
did you call rob
goodwin or did he call you
i believe i called him
do you recall telling the police in your
official statement that you're
not sure
whether
you reached out to lauren
or whether rob called you
i don't specifically recall that but
understand
i was in somewhat of a
in extremis i had just been on the
telephone when i heard gunshots and my
client telling me she's been shot in the
chest i wasn't exactly focusing on who
called whom
at that very moment well you were
very
definitive in court today with regards
to who called who correct correct and
would you agree with me on page seven
of the transcript
yeah i either reached out to lauren or
rob called me yeah okay okay
that's different than your definitive
answer that you gave on correct well i
would assume you have the copies of the
telephone records that would determine
who called whom
right i mean how hard is that to get
not at all but okay
all right hold on a second getting a
little argumentative here
just answer the questions if there's any
follow-up
mr shellhorn can ask you questions i
have thought about it and of course i
called rob
so if i said
at this moment when i was in extremist
that i didn't recall whether i called
him or he called her that wasn't the
first thing on my mind the first thing
on my mind was reporting that my
client's been shot by your client
so
that's what really was important to me
at that moment not who called him
okay
do you remember telling the prosecutor
that uh i think i've reached out to him
but i couldn't swear correct
i don't recall that
if it's in the transcript i assume i
said it
again
in extremis
right now
irrespective of who called who
you're talking to rob goodwin correct
correct
and and what did you say to rob goodman
rob can i speak to lauren
and lauren's the one who's in control of
everything correct based on your i don't
know what that means
lauren was my client
so i was calling to speak to lauren
did you say to the prosecutor's office
words to the effect that if you get to
know rob you'll know that lauren was the
one who actually was really handling
this
did you make a statement like that i
certainly could have lauren was going to
make the decision she was my client
you're talking to rob
and
at what point at what point
when you first
got on the phone you were talking to rob
goodwin correct
i said four words to him okay
and then the phone
was put in lauren's hand correct correct
do you recall rob yelling
in the background
or speaking loudly either one
specifically no
i guess you
turn to page nine
the sixth edge from the top
can you read it and and see if that
refreshes your recollection
as to after
you were talking to lauren cataract you
heard rob yelling in the background or
talking loudly
yeah i i see that
and then could you go down one two three
more eggs
and then did you say
or do you recall straight down yeah
you're refreshing his recollection
do you recall
hearing a gunshot at that
maybe the washington township police
department
did you have a discussion with them with
regards to this incident
i was trying to get somebody on the
phone it actually may have been and i
no recollection of who told me but i
reached out to john and kirby counteract
lauren's parents i reached out to
the washington township police
department
and did all these people tell you that
lauren cataract had been shot
somebody told me that lauren canaric had
been shot
i don't know if all of them told me i
know i spoke to all of them at some
point within that that gestalt but i
don't couldn't tell you
definitively
who told me that lauren actually had
been shot do you recall telling the
prosecutor's office that when you heard
whatever you heard you didn't think
gunshot
no that i i
i don't recall saying it but i'm certain
that that's what happened because you
don't believe gunshot i'm driving up 280
trying to speak to my client that's all
so so imagine how out of outer worldly
it would be
to hear what you think are gunshots
but you just don't believe it and i just
didn't you know you don't want to
believe it but i believed it enough
to call 9-1-1 right away so something
inside me must have said to yourself
this could be real or
either that
and correct me if i'm alone or lauren
cataract saying that she was shot
well we know lauren was shot so well how
do you know lauren is shot at that point
at that very moment because she told me
she was shot
okay and did you tell the prosecutor
that you did not think
gunshot
when you gave your statement yes or no
i can't answer that question yes or no
can you refer to page
9 of the transcript the second ed from
the
bottom and tell me whether that
refreshes your recollection with regards
to whether you told the morris county
prosecutor's office
that after you heard
rob goodwin yelling
you hear something but you don't think
gunshots
as i explained to you before
when something so out of context occurs
you don't immediately go to something
that
in your wildest imagination could occur
right if
if it has stripes and hooves you think
zebra
right
i wasn't thinking gunshot there there
there was no reason to think gunshot but
obviously i must have because i called
9-1-1
do you recall telling anyone that the
noise that you heard
sounded like something heavy dropping no
i don't think i ever told anybody that
at that point
after you hear
whatever you hear
did you say the phone dropped at that
point
yes
and was that immediately after you
hearing whatever you heard no
when was that
maybe 10 seconds later
after she said i've been shot in the
heart something to words to that effect
then i'm saying lauren what's going on
what's up hello hello i heard what i
thought was the phone dropping okay and
and that's approximately 10
seconds
after you hear what you hear correct
10 15 seconds yeah and at that point you
hear scuffling correct yes
but then i hung up
at some point in time after
you believed you heard the phone drop
did you hear someone pick up the phone
call
when you look at page 10
the last ad on the body
page 10
oh so that's how it happened okay
that that's possible so can you say let
me ask you guys
you say
you heard what you thought the phone
dropped correct
yes now this refreshed my recollection
at some point in time
did someone pick up that phone
i said here the phone must have been
picked up okay now let me ask you a
question
that was
after you heard whatever sound you heard
correct
yes
that's for sure i heard the sound first
is that one
at that point lauren cataract makes the
statements
she gave to you okay yes and you were
incorrect on your previous i i stand
corrected yes
i gotta understand this was four years
ago and i haven't looked at this in four
years
and after lauren cataract
makes the statements
strike that did she say i'm losing
consciousness
she might have
can you look on page 11
four edge from the bottom and see if
that refreshes your recollection as
to whether one of the things that lauren
cataract said to you is i'm losing
consciousness
yes
yeah it does refresh my my right and you
recall or saying that correct yes
did the phone drop again
after that statement
well i i think so
because
at some point i realized she wasn't on
the other end of the phone any longer
and that's when i disconnected the call
and
call i believe i called her back
or called rob's phone
again um
right away
and uh
didn't there was nobody who picked up
and that's when i did i guess i pulled
over and decided to call 911
now
based on your
meetings
meeting or contact with lauren panoramic
did you get the impression that she
wasn't afraid of michael barrasso
no i i got the impression she was very
afraid of michael barrasso can you
please turn to page
15
[Applause]
the fifth bed from the top
and see if that represses your
recollection as to whether or not you
got the impression that lauren cataract
was not afraid of michael barrasso
i'm on page 15 please just direct me to
where you want me to go two three four
five eggs from the top
oh at that very moment yes i got the
gift
you know you put that out of context
lauren was afraid of michael barrasson
at at this particular period of time
after speaking with mr tarshish
and and really making a significant
headway in resolving this whole thing
and de-escalating the situation
yeah i i
think lauren was not afraid of him at
all not at that very moment no right
before the shooting right before the
shooting
because the whole thing was being
resolved i when you say the whole thing
was going to be resolved
you would never
talk to lauren cataract prior to the
shooting with respect to your
conversations with tarshists regarding
resolving this case correct
i don't recall
isn't it isn't the fact that you called
them on that day to reprise him of your
conversation with tarshish i had called
them on that day to apprise her of where
we were at that particular moment in
time i had been on the phone with
tarshish
since the day before
trying to resolve this
now
prior to this day
did you get the impression that the
issues between barristone and cataract
had been going on for
weeks if not longer
did i have that impression yes
now would you agree that
what you were hearing traumatized you
yes
and would you agree that
that could have an impact on your
recollection of events correct
no
incorrect
the fact that i heard gunshots
is immutable
i heard gunshots the fact that lauren
said i've been shot in the chest is
immutable i heard that and it happened
no amount of trauma is going to change
that
there are things that
which you reminded me of there were
other things that that happened
that i now recollect
but i will never ever forget
that moment in time
just looking through my notes i could
just have a second i believe i'm almost
done
so
did you have the impression that uh
michael barrasson's girlfriend was uh
creating issues
with cataract embarrassment
i was
i was informed that that was the case
prior to
the shooting
redirect
two points your honor
thank you
good mayor approach the witness
sure
mr david for the record that spin mark
is s442
directing your attention to lines
uh eight i believe it's lines eight and
nine
do you see a minimum number on those
lines
yes and i'm not going to ask you to put
your phone number on the record i would
not do that but is that your phone
number yes it is and does that
your cell phone
does that indicate uh whether or not and
without telling us whether or not there
was an incoming call or an outgoing call
related to that number
i'm sorry without telling you whether it
was an incoming or outcome just to look
at it to refresh your memory yes it
refreshes my memory does that refresh
your memory and does that confirm to you
whether or not you made the call to mr
goodwin or you received the call 100
i i made that call
i made one two calls
actually three calls which makes perfect
sense
and can you explain to the jury and i'll
just take this back what your
recollection is about the three calls
that you made
the first call which appears to be four
minutes
um
was my call to rob to
tell lauren
um
what's going on in the case and my
discussions with tarshish and when she
got shot and
whatever
the second call was after i disconnected
the first call
to see if she was okay
and my recollection is she didn't or rob
didn't pick up
um and then i did it again because you
know
you just keep on calling until
until you're sure somebody picks up or
you're sure somebody's not going to pick
up and i guess after that call
after the third call
is when i called 911.
now you were asked a question about the
handwritten notes that i think were
marked as d
1200 d
when you had actually
written those notes to yourself or
written down what you recalled yes and i
think your answer on cross-examination
was that you thought it might have been
sometime in that first 24 hours or no
more than 24 hours yes
i'm going to direct your attention and i
don't know if you still have it in front
of you i have a transcript
12 months
yes judge 1200 okay thank you for the
direct your attention if you would to
page 21.
yep
specifically on page 21 if you look uh
approximately halfway down the page or
so
yes where i believe that the detective
asked uh you were kind enough to give us
a copy of your report yeah of your notes
rather yes does that refresh your memory
reading that about approximately when
you wrote the notes down
respected to the the incident occurring
yes and it it
jives with what i've been saying
i got back to my office i wrote down the
notes it's my practice i do it 100
percent of the time not 99 100 of the
time i write down contemporaneous notes
scan them and
i believe throughout the original this
one i may have kept i may not have i
don't have it i don't know if i gave it
to
to somebody from the prosecutor's office
i don't know and approximately how far
after the incident occurring did you
write those notes down to yourself
within an hour
i mean right away i signed it i i signed
it i believe when we met
when i met with the investigator
judge no further questions
you may step down thank you sir thank
you
should i leave this here yes please
thank you sir
mr shellhorn you're under subject to
moving evidence of state rest
all right very
good all right ladies and gentlemen the
state has rested their case subject to
moving in some evidence which we're
going to address right now
during at least part of the lunch in
recess
and then we'll begin the defense case in
the afternoon so um enjoy your lunch
we're a little bit early but you can
take until uh 1 30 or so and we'll
hopefully have all the legal issues
resolved and we'll begin the defense
case then
all right thank you please don't discuss
the case during your lunch and recess
so
on the record
um
um
[Music]
might be seated ladies and gentlemen
we're ready to proceed with the defense
case
sorry for the slight delay we did have
to address some legal issues which have
been taken care of we'll now move on to
the defense case mr blinkers call your
first witness please joseph blattner
joseph blatler to the stand please
please remain standing place your left
hand on the bible
do you serve in the presence of almighty
god that the testimony goes to this
court regarding this matter shall be the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth yes i do please state your
name as well your last name for the
record joseph j blatler b l
a e tt
thank you all right you may have a seat
sir
please keep your voice up nice and loud
that microphone does not um it only
records it doesn't project your voice in
a courtroom and also you have to keep
your voice up if you don't understand
the question please indicate that and
i'll have counsel rephrase the question
yes all right and if you hear an
objection stop answering
until the court rules on the objection
all right very good sir mr blank just go
ahead thank you
mr blakely where do you live
i live in morristown
what do you do for an occupation i'm a
private investigator
do you have a
company name yes east coast private
investigations in new jersey and can you
give us a little bit of your background
please
my background i'm a retired deputy chief
of police from the city of union city i
was there for 23 years after retiring i
became a private investigative slash
police consultant
and who have you consulted for
numerous
law firms county suffolk
georgetown law center
and the name of your company is what sir
east coast private investigations of new
jersey uh do you know my client michael
barroso
just by name
and uh
were you contacted at any point in a
professional capacity by michael
barrasso yes
and and when was that
on or about july 31st of 2019.
and uh
did he hire you to do something
yes what did he hire you to do
he asked me to conduct two background
checks for him
and can you tell me the names of the two
people he had to do background checks i
believe one was goodwin and the other
one was i don't know how to pronounce
the names of the k.a
cataract cataract
right and and did you did you do a
background check on both of those
individuals yes i did
and did you provide your background
check to mr barriston after you
completed it yes i did
i'm going to show you what's been marked
defense exhibit 700 a1
and ask you
if you recognize this document
so
these are the background checks i
conducted however this one document i
don't recognize
we
sorry
after you uh
conducted
your business
uh did you provide michael barrasson
with a copy of 700 a1
yes i did
did you have any other discussions with
michael barroson
i did have other discussions with them
but i really don't recall what they were
all right
judge i move in 781
in seven
hey objects
the objection is sustained
go ahead mr malinkas with regards to the
background check and i do not want you
to say anything specific
what does that background check look at
looks sad people's previous residents
relatives phone numbers
liens judgments bankruptcies criminal
histories
it's
uh employment comes up sometimes
any close examination briefly judge mr
blatler you never met uh robert goodwin
no and you never met lauren canara no
and you didn't
confirm or corroborate any of the
information that showed up in the
background check no
did you and you told mr barristone
certain methods that he could do to
verify these things if you wanted to yes
if you wish to follow up thank you sir
no further questions judgment all right
you may step down sir
i'm sorry mr blink is any redirect
you may step down thank you sir
thank you mr clayton
defense calls larry davison
mr davidson
hi mr davidson please remain standing
for a moment if you would please
place your left hand on that bible uh
raise your right hand listen to my court
clerk please
do you sway in the presence of almighty
god that the testimony goes to this
court regarding this matter shall be the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth
yes i do please state your name as for
your last name for the record lawrence
davidson
d-a-v-i-d-s-o-n
thank you
all right you may have a seat sir please
keep your voice up nice and loud
that microphone only records it it does
not project your voice in the courtroom
all right so you have to keep your voice
up if you don't understand the question
please indicate that i'll have counsel
rephrase
if you hear any counsel object uh please
stop answering until the court resolves
that objection go ahead mr blancas thank
you dude
mr davidson uh where do you live
uh glenn gardner new jersey
and and can you tell the ladies and
gentlemen the jury what you do for a
living
i drive a truck
and who do you work for specifically uh
robert jenkins to the nursery
and and what do you specifically do for
them just drive hall trees okay
uh do you know my client michael
barrison yes i do
how long have you known him i see a
smile on your face
how long have you known him uh probably
20 years anyway
okay and how do you know him
i've known from
the farm
you know
i you know worked for him
brought hay in for him and stuff like
that
okay
did there come a time
uh in august of 2019
where michael barristone hired you to do
something other than
all hay or
deliver things from the nursery yes
what did he hire you to do he asked me
to uh watch what's the bar
and when you say watch the barn yeah
what were you watching for
uh
well he was having problems with the
girl that was in the house and i don't
even know her name or anything
and in hiring did he express concerns
about her yes
and is that specifically why
he asked you to uh to come there yes
and what time would you come um during
the day
uh probably like eight o'clock at night
i wouldn't be there during the day just
at night time okay and uh
what time did you leave
uh like six o'clock in the morning
i i had coffee with uh mike and
trying to talk to him but he was so
he was so
i don't know just so messed up that he
couldn't even hardly talk
all right so uh do you recall the first
time uh you came to the property uh um
on a particular night
oh the first time first time yeah
i was uh driving up there
and the girl comes out of the house
comes running out of the house
and says who are you who are you who are
you i just kept on going
and i got up to the
farm and i saw mike
and uh
and then
sat there for maybe 10 10 minutes
and two cars come up the driveway
and i said oh boy
at some point in time um did those
people in those two cars identify
themselves
well
yeah one one around the barn
and one pulled up by me
and and they were police so they were
unmarked cars i don't know where they
were
and uh did you have a discussion with
the police
just all he said was uh
how's everything i said it was quiet
right now and that was it
and he left did they ask you what you
were doing there or why you were hired
by michael barrison no nothing
nothing
now so um
i'm not sure
if you told us the first day that you
came here where this incident happened
was that august 1st i believe so yes
okay and
did you come there
each night thereafter
to the day of the incident yes
and uh
each night what what would you do
what was your life job
just to park
by the barn make sure nobody goes in a
bar
okay and
during that week leading up to the
shooting did you have the occasion to
see michael barrison i seen mike every
night yep
he he constantly was walking the
property
constantly walking the property you mean
after hours
yeah all night
all night he was walking the property
and did you have an opportunity to
observe him physically
like his
physical appearance
yes it was he wasn't i don't know he was
just terri terrible he just
he just couldn't he was beside himself
and you've known him for how long
20 years have you ever seen him anywhere
near in this condition during that
20-year period never
and
with regards to your observation
what specifically
did you observe about his physical
appearance
he was just
just distraught he was uh
i mean he could hardly talk he could
hardly talk
we used to have coffee in the morning
he'd be he'd be sitting
at the desk there and
i'm trying to talk to him and
he was just
he was out of he was out of it
now you said you you observed him
walking the property
every night every night i was there
what hours of the night
well i got there like eight or nine
o'clock
and he was he was up all night all night
he come out and see me
and then he go back
you know back around again and be on the
porch and then come back out again
and how many times would he do this
on each night
probably three or four times a night
come out you know by me
did you notice anything in the way he
was dressing that was different than you
uh you previously observed prior to
these uh
i have nothing freddie
mr shell horn any cross-examination just
briefly judge go ahead mr davis good
afternoon
do you remember
being interviewed by members of the
prosecutor's office on october 2nd 2020
where was that at
did they did they meet you at the
hundred and county hospital center yeah
do you remember that interview yes you
probably talked to them for about an
hour that day yeah
and you didn't mention anything to them
during the course of that interview
about anyone running out of the house or
trying to flag you down
i don't know maybe i did i don't know
we didn't talk about that
you would agree with me that uh during
the time that you were there at the farm
on the overnights no one ever tried to
come and enter the barn during the times
you were there no
no the only one
what guy
you know
surprised me was mike
he come here walking up by the truck
okay mike
nothing further thank you
all right any redirect no jeff all right
you may step down sir thank you mr
davidson thank you
mr malinkas go ahead defense calls
christiana cook slash gibbs
all right miss uh christiana
gibbs cook gibbs
hi ma'am just remain standing for a
moment if you can place your left hand
on the bible on the witness stand
please raise your right hand and listen
to my question
please when the presence of almighty god
that the testimony give to this court
regarding this matter shall be the truth
the whole truth and nothing but the
truth i do please state your name for
your last name for the record christiana
cook gibbs
c-o-o-k-e hyphen gi bbs thank you all
right miss cook gibbs you may have a
seat please keep your voice up nice and
loud
like that microphone does not um project
your voice and just record so you have
to speak loudly if you don't understand
the question please indicate that
go ahead mr malinkas thank you
ms gibson where are you i live in
alamuchi new jersey and uh
who are you employed by i'm employed by
the township of washington and mars
county
and uh can you briefly describe your
your background i'm i have a
bachelor's of science degree in animal
science i have my master's in public
health
okay uh who do you currently work for
washington township morris county
and what uh what's your specific
position
my specific title is that i'm the health
officer for the health department of
washington township
and how long you've been doing that
i've been employed by washington
township for 36 years
and and what does that entail like
what's your
job description
um
being a rural
community the bulk of my position it was
i'm charged with administrating
administering laws that protect public
health
both municipal and state
a lot of my job involves environmental
work septics and wells we do
everything from rabies to food
inspections
last two years covet
okay
did you have an occasion to respond to
my client michael barrasso's property on
august 6th
i did
and and before we get to that
um
prior to that day
um did you know michael barrasson i did
and how did you know him uh through
dealings with the property um
the property was a farm
and um at some point
in the late 1990s it was developed into
a dressage facility and a large
equestrian center was built
and i was involved with the permitting
of both the front home that was moved
and made into a double home and then the
equestrian center in the back so well
and septic permits i was involved with
from the beginning of the development of
the property and
then somewhere
michael wasn't my primary contact with
the property
but eventually
michael turned out to be my point person
there and i remember there was a septic
problem
um
in about 10 years in and we had to rep
rebuild the septic and at that point
michael was was the point person for the
property okay so prior to the six
over the years you've had an opportunity
to
uh come in contact with michael and
observe him um
in normal day affairs correct yes sir
and how would you describe them
in those days
um
very confident
very dignified elegant man
you know
on the sixth
uh do you know uh who signed the
complaint against the
michael barrasson that caused you to go
to the property well have we established
that
i want to ask some
foundational questions
why did you go to the property
i went to the property because a
complaint
was
received by another department in the
township
the bill the construction department
received a complaint
alleging
that unpermitted work had happened at
the property
and
ancillary to that it would have involved
my department there was allegations that
an apartment was constructed
in the barn
and and therefore
it would have impacted my authority and
how does that impact your
authority department in the world
because the septic system for the barn
was only sized to accommodate a certain
amount of flow septics are designed for
gallons and that septic was only
designed
for a very specific purpose and not to
accommodate living space
okay and uh
prior to going to the property
did you ascertain who made it
i
i don't recall i
the complaint was not made directly to
me i did not have any interaction with
the complaint before i went on the
property okay
now when you said you went on the
property
did
anyone else go with you
i
specifically drove to the property with
my colleague from the health department
but we met there at the same time with
representatives of the construction
department and the fire official
so we all can kind of convened on the
property at the same time in different
vehicles
there could have there would have been
at least three vehicles maybe four but
at least three
okay and uh
at some point in time
did you have an opportunity
to observe michael barrasso yes i did
and uh
did you observe him before
you and the other town officials started
doing your job so to speak walking
around and looking at things
we originally um arrived to the property
and and got out of the cars at the house
in the front the two family house
took a look around
didn't appear that anyone was there we
knocked on the doors
no one was there so we were getting in
the cars to go back the barn is quite a
distance off the road and then
the
gentleman who i found out who was the
complaint and arrived
spoke to
a con the construction official i i
backed away from the conversation i
wasn't part of it
and again when you say the person that
made the complaint who was that
i
i believe his name was robert but i
don't i don't particularly remember his
last name woodward yes
now you indicated that uh
when robert goodwin started talking to
the construction officials you backed
away i did why did you do that i just
didn't didn't get a good feeling about
you know he didn't complain to me he
didn't reach out to me and i just
just i i literally backed away
did there come a time when you uh
went up towards the stable area the barn
area yes we did we we all got in our
cars and we proceeded
up to the stable
and at that point
did you have an opportunity to see
michael barrasso i did
he and um mr lundberg who was the
gentleman who i had originally dealt
with on the property from the beginning
we're outside
sitting on the porch i recall
and
we
mr lumber got up and came and greeted me
and i then walked back with mr lundberg
and we spoke with michael at the time to
let him know why we were there okay
and
you mentioned the name lundberg and
someone that you were dealt with is he
michael's a partner in that staple as
far as you know
i don't know what the uh official
relationship was between mr barizone and
mr lundberg but i assume it was a
a business
arrangement and a you know
a mutual passion for what they were
doing there
now
do you recall when you first observed
michael barisson on that day i do
and can you tell the ladies and
gentlemen of the jury what your
impressions were when you first saw him
he was very distraught
very disheveled
very very upset
can you describe his physical appearance
um
unlike my prior meetings with him he was
he he was very very very different he
was
you know sweating and
pacing and
mumbling
did he appear to have bathed recently
i don't remember
i i couldn't get that specific but it
was
much much different than any prior
meeting that i had had with him
would shocking be a reasonable term
it was very subjection
that's a little leaning mr belinkas
sustained
how would you describe
your observations
previously
with the observations on
august 6th
a very different person
in what way
he was
he was disheveled he was
upset
he was
undone
he
um
he wasn't the competent
guy that i remember and um very very uh
he made
comments about
being fearful
uh objection judge
it's not yes
that's hearsay
you cannot you can only describe what
you okay your observations of mr
barisson as you've done but there's
nothing nothing that was said okay that
would be hearsay
anything else that
pops into your mind regarding your
observations of him
uh no what was your your impression of
him
based on your observations
he was very very distraught and
and
very very different
nothing further
cross-examination
gibbs had you ever met the individual
that you referred to as robert goodwin
before that day i had not
and did you uh
feel like after meeting him that he
didn't fit there
objection
what's the basis for the objection
the impression
yeah i mean
you had her
describe what she did when she met him
and that's seems to be
follow-up
do you recall when you were interviewed
by members of the washington township
police department on september 17th of
2019.
i i honestly didn't didn't remember it
until i got subpoenaed um
but now i do remember being
interviewed it was a long time ago
do you recall telling them that you you
felt like mr goodwin didn't fit there i
did
i do
you showed or you and the other township
officials came to the property on august
6 unannounced
we did i i mean i don't know if the
construction department
announced i i went there unannounced i
can speak for myself only
meaning the health department did not
notify anyone that they were coming
that's correct
did you ever observe uh mr mr barrissone
during a training session
actually
yes um
i was on the property once
to um
watch a horse
and i i believe mr barrisson was there
what was his demeanor during the course
of that training session very
professional
now
you responded on august 6 to investigate
potential health issues or environmental
issues that's correct and did you
identify health issues and environmental
issues
i observed um
i observed work that was done without
permits that would have required
the health department involvement i
didn't um an environmental issue like an
end result of of it no uh but
you know i didn't i didn't observe a
malfunctioning septic or something like
that but i did observe work that should
have been permitted and and should have
been reviewed and authorized before it
was done
for example that the septic system would
have been overloaded by the number of
bathrooms or something of that nature
right which could have could have led to
a problem down the road if it wasn't
located and identified by you on august
6th
uh
yes
no further questions judge
just one more
go ahead can you explain
why you didn't feel like robert goodwin
didn't fit in there
when you never really met him before
i just got a bad feeling i just i don't
know what
nothing further
all right you may step down man thank
you very much
all right mr blinkers call your next
witness
bill her wagon
mr bill her wagon
hello sir hello
please remain standing place your left
hand on that bible and just turn this
way face my lawn clerk she'll administer
my court clerk excuse me
do you swore the presence of almighty
god that the testimony given to this
court regarding this matter shall be the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth
yes i do please state your name as well
your last name for the record william
herrera jr h-e-e-r-w-a-g-e
thank you
all right very good sir have a seat
please keep your voice up nice and loud
if you don't understand a question from
council please indicate that i'll have
them rephrase
go ahead mrs
good afternoon uh where do you currently
reside
i live in uh washington township warren
county
and what do you do for a living
uh
currently i am a life safety instructor
for surgery centers
i'm a retired firefighter okay back in
august specifically august 6 2019 what
did you do i was the fire inspector for
washington township morris county and
can you give the ladies and gentlemen
and jury a little bit of your background
working with washington township yes
or your previous employment that
allows you to become
you were there
i was uh
a retired firefighter a fire captain
from maplewood new jersey i am also a uh
was a fire marshal for washington
township warren county
washington township mars county and
several other
towns independence in mansfield
okay and
back in
august of 2019
um
did you have an occasion to respond to
my client michael barrisson's uh farm
yes i did
and and
why did you respond it was at the
request of the at the fire marshal at
that
time
he asked me to take a ride with him to
issue uh violations
and and
to your knowledge was a complaint filed
at that time i wasn't aware of anything
though so basically you're just asked to
come along for the ride right correct
and
and uh prior to that day had you had
occasion to see michael barrasson before
no not at all
so on the sixth that was the first time
uh that you ever laid eyes on michael
barrisson correct that's correct
and and
can you describe his demeanor when you
first saw
when we arrived he approached us and
it was a
short dialogue and he was seemed very
upset to the point where he actually
started sobbing
actual sopping
more than crying crying
i use the word sobbing as far as crying
did you ever determine
why he was crying or what issues he had
um
later on
uh
i'm going to object on speculation great
judgment
yeah
let me see that sidebar
you can rephrase if you wish to sure
mr wagon um
with regards to these uh
code
violations did you when you were
his boss or colleague
determined
who was doing the construction
at the facility
that was more on my boss's part okay
all right i have nothing further thank
you
any cross-examination of mr hugh wagon
briefly judge uh mr wagon do you know if
the visit to the property was announced
to mr barrisson before you went there
uh
no i was not aware if it was or not i
know it was a second visit to the
property where my boss supervisor was
there earlier in the debt
where he uh i guess he viewed what was
supposed to have been
written up now he went back later that
afternoon to issue the construction
violations
and when you talk about uh
that individual is that mr lopez that's
correct who else was at the property
when you were there from from the
township
uh neil giro he was the construction
official at the time
do you recall if ms cook gibbs was there
at that time no she was not i know she
wasn't there at the time it was just the
three of us
and you indicated that you had gone
there in your capacity uh as a
related to the fire inspection i was
asked to go along as a second party he
was issuing violations and he felt that
it was best to have somebody with him
and there were actual fire violations
located at the property
i believe so i did not see exactly what
they were mr lopez would be more aware
of what exactly he wrote up i didn't
write it up
no further questions judge
all right
can you redirect no you may step down mr
hugh wagon thank you sir
call your next witness sir
matthew lopez
yes mr matthew lopez please
hi mr lopez please remain standing for a
minute left hand on the bible raise your
right hand please listen to my court
clerk do you certain the presence of
almighty god that the testimony gives to
this court regarding this matter shall
be the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth i will please state your
name as well your last name for the
record uh matthew lopez thank you oh you
may have a seat sir please keep your
voice up
that microphone only records it doesn't
project your voice in the courtroom so
keep your voice up so everyone can hear
if you don't understand the question
please indicate that i'll have counsel
rephrase very good mr malinkas go ahead
mr lopez
what do you do for olympia
i'm a fire inspector
and for who for washington township
morris county and how long have you been
can you hear okay
sort of i see it's uh yeah leaning
forward a little bit try to keep and
there's a hand back there yeah i i
thought that just keep your voice up
nice and loud
go ahead
fire inspector for washington township
correct
and how long you've been doing that
about 10 years
and what what training or experience you
have to to hold the position like that i
have a fire inspector fire official
certification to the state
and you've been doing that for 10 years
at washington township washington
and
directing your attention to august 6
did you respond to my client's
farm
in washington township i did
and
had you received a complaint
we did
i can approach i show you
d 102
and ask you
if you recognize that document i do
recognize that
and is that the reason why uh you
decided to go out there on the uh
sixth that's correct
now prior to going out did you talk to
anybody about that
um
that complaint
we received the complaint and we decided
to go out to investigate the next day
okay and and uh
two people signed that complaint correct
that's correct and prior to going out
did you
attempt to contact
those people and
try to see what you were dealing with
uh we did not okay
so
does that complaint
accurately
depict
the reasons why you went out on that
particular day
yes stated fire code violations were at
the property okay
judge i move uh
d100 e2 into evidence
jack judge
what's the basis for the objection
same objection that i had with the prior
document i think this is hearsay
it's not an offer for the truth
it is offered for the truth let me see
it come the sidebar please
all right rephrase your question mr
balinkas mr lopez uh in the complaint
to object to that judge
yeah just
it's your witness mr blankets you can
ask him
what he did without getting into the
specifics
with regards to the
farmhouse
specifically the basement area
did you go and check
down there
to determine whether there were any
violations
yes we went down in the basement
and and what were you checking for
we were looking down in the basement we
were looking for fire code violations
uh
we were looking to see if anyone was
staying down there
and if there was any other violations
such as
uh you know open wiring and missing fire
protection devices and
were people staying down there
there was nobody there when we were
there
you checked the rest of the house
correct that was correct
and uh
based on your uh inspection
did you wish you violations yes we did
what specifically did you issue
we issued a imminent hazard for the
house
and for the barn
okay let's let's talk about the house
first
what were the issues with the house
the house uh
had
zero smoke hardwired smoke alarms
they were all missing from the ceiling
um
and then there was additional there was
open wiring throughout the building and
missing fire rated construction
from the first and second floor
i'm sorry what did you say about the
first and second floor i didn't catch
that it was missing firey to
construction
uh the ceiling was missing from the
first floor to the second floor
okay
and and based on
those
observations
um
did you issue a violation yes
and what's the result of you issuing the
violation what are the consequences so
to speak
um the owner operator of the property
would have to abate the violations
within the time frame that code allowed
and
is someone obligated to
move out
and
remain out of the residence until
those specific issues are addressed with
an imminent hazard
nobody has to go back into the property
unless it is to beat
the imminent hazard
right
i've seen pictures of
violations posted on the
back door did you post those i did
nobody was at the property at the house
when the the violations were issued so i
posted it on the building so anybody
that came back saw the violations were
aware
right now
would you
strike that
what does the violation say
are the consequences to anyone
who ignores those violations and goes in
and resides in the residence
there's fines involved with that
up to five thousand dollars correct
and who's the owner of that property
based on your
investigation uh i had sweet grass
farms uh and barcelona um dressage as
the owner operator and that's michael
barisson's company you know correct uh
yes
now
so i understand uh the sequence of
events
you place a violation on the
door of the
farmhouse correct yes
and
there's another
stack of papers posted also what is that
uh i'm not sure why don't you show them
the photograph
if you have it
well when you make your determination
that there's a violation and
that people must leave what do you post
on the uh the doors
i post the notice of violation after
i've issued it to the property owner
so at some point in time you go up to
the stable area correct
correct
and and uh
did you
post a similar type of violation
on that structure
i don't believe i did
i hand delivered it to
uh
mr barcode
and when you say you hand delivered it
to who my client correct yes
and
was he basically based on your
your inspection
not allowed to
re-enter the property
and sleep there
i know nobody can stay there until the
imminent hazard has been abated
can we clarify which property you're
speaking about i'm talking i thought i
did the stable area
i show you d800
81
and ask
if if you know what those two pieces of
paper tape to the back door
the one is my imminent hazard i'm not
sure what that other one is well who who
put that on the door
i know i i put the one on the left on
the door i don't recall what the one in
the middle is
i'm not sure what that one is in the
middle
well how many
packets do you normally put on a door
based on the violations that you
observed on that day i normally just
issue the imminent hazard of the notice
violation
[Music]
i show you d500 slash five
and ask you if you recognize this stuff
yes that's the imminent hazard that's
posted on the left
okay and and basically what is what's
the purpose of this document
this document was posted the building
had an imaging hazard and anybody that
went to the building or tried to get
into the building knew that there was an
imminent hazard and was able to read
it and as you sit here today
i'm going to show you 872
which is the other document on the door
do you recognize that document
yes that's the letter for temporary
housing that the town had
asked the post
okay
judge i i move
872
which is the
letter from the town posted on the door
that's already been introduced into
evidence and the
specific
500-5
as well as defense exhibit 881
which shows both documents
i think if it's the two pictures
and the actual violation that was posted
i don't have an objection
can i just confirm yeah just show mr
shellhorn what it is you're moving in
specifically
thank you
what are those numbers again mr malinkas
800-81
800-72
which is the letter
and the specific violation 500-5
but those matters will be admitted into
evidence no objection from the state and
i'd like to publish these to
interrogation certainly
i'm putting on the
screen
800-810
are you going to turn the image please
judge if i could
just quickly show the jury very quickly
sure
800-72 the letter
and
finally
500-5 feet
notice of eminent hazard
that was posted on the door
thank you
that's
i'm not going to ask you the specifics
but did you have a conversation with
michael barrasson about
where he
and all the people who were residing in
the stable area were going to sleep
yes
and did you come back at any point and
see
mattresses laid out outside on the front
porch yes i did
and when did you see those mattresses on
the back porch um at the time that the
violation of the imminent hazard had
stated
now
did michael
barrasson
and all these staff members there
complied with your order
to vacate the premises
they debated the violation by not
sleeping there and removing the
mattresses so yes
now
did you have any discussions with lauren
cataract
with regards to her staying in the
farmhouse
she emailed us stating that she had
received the violations yes
so you got confirmation she was aware of
that correct
correct
now
and i can't ask you what you said or
what she said
but did you come to an arrangement
with lauren cataract
where upon she was allowed to stay in
the farmhouse
she
and michael are robert goodwin updated
the imminent hazard
and therefore the imminent hazard was
abated
and
i could not there's no reason for me to
be able to keep them out
you basically gave them permission
based on what under the fire code under
the fire code to go back into that
residence correct because the imminent
hazard was abated
and to your knowledge did
she or robert goodwin take down
those violations that were
return to the scene and we haven't
established that yet did you return to
the scene at any point when to check to
see whether those violations were abated
no it was late at the night and they
sent me emails with photos of everything
in working order and video of the smoke
alarms working
so
you did that based on what they told you
not what you
saw or investigated correct
it was late at night and i was not going
to go out to the farm late at night they
sent us emails and videos of all the
devices working properly okay
now
when michael barissone was
violated for the stable area
did you advise him
of the violations concerning the
farmhouse because he was the owner i did
now
after you allowed cataract and goodwin
to go back into the residence did you at
any time notify michael barristone the
owner
what you had done
not that night i didn't
we were going to do it in the morning
did you do it in the morning
i did not get to it in the morning no we
did not meant no so as far as michael
barrasson was concerned objection
yes mr blencus not proper sustained
so before the shooting
did you notify michael barrasson
that cataract and goodwin
were allowed to remain in the residence
i did not have contact information for
michael some now
did you or anyone on your behalf
go out and remove those violation
notices
nobody from my office removed the
violation notices
and those are the violation notices that
i showed you in that kitchen correct
the ones that were on the door of the
house yes
sure
do you have anything to do with the uh
stop construction orders
no that's that's ucc construction
i have nothing for you
cross-examination
thank you honor
so mr lopez uh
you were there on august 6th and issued
a number of fire violations at the house
correct and you also issued a number of
fire violations at the barn correct and
i think just to clear up what what you
were just asked about
you got an email from ms canorack on
the night of august 6 2019 correct and
she actually sent you videos and
pictures that showed that there were
fire detector smoke detectors and things
of that nature yes
and from your perspective that abated
the hazard that you had observed the
imminent hazard at least for purposes of
that night correct
when you were at the property at some
point on august 6th mr bolinkis asked
you about seeing mattresses outside
the barn correct
and during the course of dealing with
michael barrasson did he tell you that
he was going to be getting a hotel
correct and you found that to be
satisfactory because
the barn is not a dwelling unit so
nobody should be staying there
whose responsibility is it to fix uh or
remedy or abate an imminent hazard
the owner operator tenant occupant
and in this case you actually had ms
canarac and mr goodwin abated what was
going on at the barn but nothing was
invaded at the
excuse me at the house but nothing was
evaded at the bar
no the barn was abated
the mattresses were removed so there was
no dwelling units inside the barn
anymore i understand
healthy further on thank you
any redirect
right you may step down mr lopez thank
you
might call your next witness
dan vitale
defense call is mr dan vitale
[Music]
um left hand on the bible please raise
your right hand please listen to my
court clerk as she administers the oath
the australian presence of almighty god
that the testimony goes to this court
regarding this matter shall be the truth
the whole truth and nothing but the
truth yes i do please state your name as
for your last name for the record daniel
vitale
v-i-t-a-l-e thank you all you may be
seated sir
please keep your voice up nice and loud
that microphone only records it does not
project your voice in the courtroom okay
all right so they have to hear your
voice if you don't understand the
question please indicate that i'll have
counsel rephrase okay all right go ahead
mr malinkas
mr vitale where do you currently live
uh i currently live in morris county
and what do you do for a living i
currently am a firefighter paramedic
directing your attention back to august
7
2019
where were you working
st clare's hospital ems
what training
do you have
to become an ems i went through emt
school and then i went through paramedic
school
to become a paramedic where i was
working at the time
and how long were you working there
prior to august 7 2019
i would say it was a few years prior
maybe
three or four years prior to that date
so
again
your title is or was exactly what back
then uh mobile intensive care paramedic
okay um on august 7th did you have an
occasion to uh come into contact with my
client michael barrison yes
and
how did that come about
we were called to
an address
and
we were dispatched there through our
dispatch center
and responded to that address where
he was located all right uh do you
recall what the address is as you sit
here today um i don't recall it's on my
patient care report okay i'm going to
show you d 600
and ask you to take a look at that and
see if that refreshes your recollection
as to where you went
and saw my client michael barrasson
411 west mill road in long valley
right and you're referring to to what an
official uh
document that was made uh yeah this this
is our patient care report
and what's included in this uh type of
report
um obviously all the dispatch dispatch
information times and our exam findings
uh were you there with someone else from
uh
saint claire's ems services yes we ride
two paramedics in new jersey so my
partner kimberly held this with me
all right
and uh at some point in time did you uh
come into contact with michael barrison
yes
and uh
did you
assess and treat him
yes
in assessing him
uh
did you attempt to determine what
happened
we did i tell you about yeah and
what was he able to tell you about the
incident
judge can we be heard at cyborg
yes
let me see that sidebar please
mr horn let me see you again please
thank you
in treating michael barrasson
did you ask him what happened
we did
and
what was his response
his response was that
someone was there to take his kids
and
he couldn't remember really much of
anything
did he give you any information as to
the actual event
no
no did you make note of his uh
present mental status
we did
and and what was your observations of
barristone
uh while you were treating him confused
did you receive
information from anyone else
at the scene
that you used as far as any uh treatment
that you did
i don't really understand the question
though okay let me try to rephrase it
i'm not sure i do either
um
did you see any injuries on michael
barason
we did yes
did you see get information from anyone
other than michael barrasson
as to
what
may have caused those injuries
we did yes
and what was that the police department
how many will object to the
form of the questions hearsay calls for
a hearsay response and those these are
statements from others not from
their statements with regards to a
specific injuries judge that he used
to determine what medical attention was
necessary
is that why did you ask others the
question
about what happened or did they
volunteer the information to you they
volunteered as we arrived on scene
and who specifically did you speak to do
you recall uh a patrolman i don't
remember his name it is reflected in my
uh patient care report he was the one
that transported with us and he gave you
information and
what was the reason did you need that
information
it's pretty typical when the paramedics
arrive on scene that the agency that's
currently there gives us an update as to
what's going on so we kind of know what
to do and who to approach who might need
our services who does not
all right so at that point in time when
you heard the statement you didn't
know who might need your services oh no
because we were just arriving on scene
right so
let me see at cyborg please
uh just rephrase the question mr
belinkas in accordance with the court's
ruling please
mrs vitale did you received information
that michael barrasson had suffered dog
bites
at the scene yes
now
did you observe
various injuries to michael barrasson's
body yes
i'm going to show you a stack of
photographs
852 to
[Music]
871.
and could you just take a a quick look
at all of those
good while the witness is looking at
those perhaps we can come to cyborg
all right you know what why don't we do
this it's 10 after three we'll take our
afternoon recess we can talk about this
outside the jury's presence
and then we'll proceed all right we'll
take ten minutes ladies and gentlemen
miss radler are there any other people
observers outside
that want to come in all right if if
you're here i'm going to ask everyone to
remain throughout the testimony if we
get a break in the witness you can get
up and leave but we i i have heard some
complaints made by the jurors that
they're distracted at points because of
people walking in and out of the
courtroom
so if you're here just remain here we
don't have too much longer today just
remain here if you have to go somewhere
at four o'clock or something then i'm
going to ask you either to stay or leave
now i don't want the jurors being
disturbed by people walking in and out
all the time
thank you
and miss radley can you just check
outside if there are anyone else that
wants to come in they need to come in
now otherwise they're not coming in
thanks
christie
i'd be seated members of the jury
members of the jury my staff did inform
me at the break that there were a couple
complaints about people walking in and
out of the courtroom during testimony
and the door slamming i've spoken to the
people in the courtroom now and told
them they have to wait until a break in
the witness testimony and my staff has
also checked out in the hallway to make
sure that people who wanted to come in
and see the testimony already in here
and hopefully we'll keep that at a
minimum
if it happens again i'll see it i i'm
sorry i missed it before but now that
i'm attuned to it i'm going to look for
it so if people start walking in and out
i'll take corrective action
sorry for the disturbance all right um
mr vitale's on the stand we'll continue
with examination go ahead mr balinkas
thank you
mr vitelli i'm going to show you these
photographs
[Music]
first 852
does
that photograph accurately depict
the injuries to michael barrisson's face
area yes
8 55
does that
photograph accurately depict
the injuries to the left side of
michael's face michael barrasson's face
yes
864 does this accurately defeat the
injuries to the right side of his face
yes
age 66 does that accurately reflect
the injuries to the
his left side yes it does
and when you were examining him he
didn't have a shirt on correct
i don't believe he had a shirt on now
and he
56 does that accurately depict
his left arm and the injury that he
suffered
you can't really see much there since
it's bandaged up but he did have
injuries to his left arm so i would
assume that's probably
okay now
with regards to his injuries did you uh
document
your initial physical findings
yes
on the patient care report
and with regards to uh
the head area what was your findings
can i refer back to the if you needed to
read the questions
has that document been marked mr
blinkist
can you just for the record in mind
600-5
thank you 600-5 is what the witness is
referring to
judge i don't have an objection to the
witness referring to that as long as the
record's clear about whether he's
testifying from his memory or from what
was documented
i think he's refreshing his recollection
now yeah yes okay
so
what were your observations
and your physical findings regarding
the head area
abrasions hematomas
what's a hematoma uh it's a bruising
to the face
yeah he had lacerations and uh
that were also on his face on all sides
too so how about his uh the face what
what did you observe on his face uh
those injuries that i just mentioned
were
on all sides of his face
his face and the left side of his head
as far in the right side of his head as
well
did you notice any injuries to
both of his ears
not specifically
do those photographs that you've
reviewed
uh
refresh your recollection with regards
to injuries of the years yes it looks
consistent yeah
how about his uh
the general back area what did you
observe there
and you could refresh your report if you
need to yeah i'll have to just look
again because uh go
again for the ahead he's returning to
his official report
with regards to his back area what did
you note
one second
uh on here i have noted that his back uh
examination appeared to be normal
uh there were there were some abrasions
otherwise normal
about the left arm
upper
the left upper arm if i could just
refresh my memory here
looks like um
his left upper arm did have uh
abrasions still
punctures
and was uh
was there any blood that you noticed
um it's not on here but i remember that
there was dry blood on there from the
abrasions and puncture wounds
right how about the right upper arm
i still uh abrasions on here
right upper abrasions yeah version some
controlled bleeding okay uh what did you
notice about his left forearm
um his left forearm
uh i do remember it was kind of weak he
was in handcuffs
but it seemed like that arm was uh
like weak difficult for him to move
compared to the other upper extremity
and did you notice any deformities in
that arm
uh
i don't specifically remember a
deformity to it but he was also in
handcuffs so his arm was already a
little
in an awkward position
did you make any reference in your
report with regards to the left form
findings
uh yeah the motor function being
abnormal slash weakness to me that was
his him moving that left arm seemed
decreased
did did you notice any puncture wounds
on the left arm
uh he
yes we did have that side of his body
had puncture ones yep
how about his left
upper leg area
his left upper leg area was bandaged
prior to my arrival so i couldn't do
much of an exam on it and did you
receive information with regards to uh
who bandaged it and for what
i will object to for what judge
for the reasons stated overwhelmed i'll
allow it
um as far as who bandaged it i don't
remember who bandaged the the injury
what was your bandage for
um
on this
yeah the for the dog bite
did you find any
any other puncture wounds on his body
left upper extremity
and the left shoulder i believe
how about his right eye
the right eye findings uh saying that
there was a laceration there which was
consistent with the rest of the
head assessment that we did prior
and what did you note based on your
observations was his uh
mental status
confused altered mental status
and did you put that in your official
report yes
it should be right on this page here
which at this time i would move into
evidence 852
55
64
66
and 56.
all right 8 52
55 56 64 and 66 will be moved into
evidence the court and council
previously
addressed any objections to those
photographs those were allowed in by the
court
okay judge my email doesn't seem to be
working i'd like to just publish him
sure go ahead
which one mr bolinkis is doing that i'll
just put on the record he's going to
determine the day when photo 66 was
taken it was not taken on the day of the
incident
he doesn't have that right now but he is
going to get it for the record
all right thank you
now now i'll display 55.
mr bilinkas are you going to walk back
and forth five separate times
i don't know any other way to do it just
hand your number one the stack of
photographs they can pass it down and
then when during number seven is done
you can take it and pass it to the
jurors just haven't passed it alone
just give him the whole stack let him
review it and then he can pass it on
thank you
you
all right mr blinkers you want to hand
those uh to juror number eight please
so
um
so
um
all right the jurors have viewed all of
the photographs
please uh proceed mr blancas no further
questions
mr horn cross-examination thank you
honor mr vitale
you s
traveled in the ambulance with the
defendant and another
uh
partner yes what was her name kimberly
held and did
patrol officer hensley ride in the
ambulance with
yes
now you indicated that mr barrissone was
alert and conscious during the transport
yes
uh
he was alert to person
person and place and place and you
didn't note any neurological deficits
no other than his confusion
his speech was normal yes
and you indicated that he made some
statements during the course of the
transport
yes
he indicated
someone drove down my driveway and said
she was going to take my kids
yes
did he also stage him you read the
entire
passage
let's sum now
was there something left out mr
shellhorn there are other comments in
there judge i just want to focus on that
part of it he left out
hold on don't say well let me see that
sidebar
okay can i see one more
and that's uh 605 for the record runner
does that indicate in quotation marks
someone drove down my driveway and said
she was going to take my kids that's all
i remember
yes
and was that putting quotation marks
because it was a direct quote it was
did the defendant also report that his
heart was hurting but not physically
that was also quoted yes
meaning that it was putting quotes into
the report because that was the exact
words that he used correct thank you mr
vitale no further questions judgment
you may step down sir thank you
you have another witness mr blancas yes
george kimberly health
all right kimberly
helm
h-e-l-d
help okay kimberly hill
hi miss held how are you good afternoon
good uh please remain standing for a
minute uh place your left hand on the
bible on the witness stand please raise
your right hand my court clerk will
administer
do you so in the presence of almighty
god that the testimony gives to this
court regarding this matter shall be the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth thank you please state your
name as well your last name for the
record kimberly health h-e-l-d thank you
oh you may have a seat man please keep
your voice up nice and loud that
microphone only records it does not
project your voice in accordance all
right very good if you don't understand
the question please indicate that to me
and i'll have counsel rephrase the
question very good mr blinkist direct
examination
hill
um
[Music]
directing your attention to uh august
7th 2019
uh where were you employed saint claire
shells
in what capacity a paramedic
and what training if any did you have as
a paramedic to
obtain that position i received an
associate's degree in paramedicine
science at bergen community college
and how long have you been working for
saint players
up to that point a little short of two
years
okay i'm going to direct your attention
to august
7 2019
did you have an occasion to respond to
4-1-1 west mill road yes
and was that michael barrasson's uh song
do you know
and why did you respond there
we were dispatched by our communications
and
upon arrival
at any point in time did you have an
opportunity to see
my client michael barrison yes did you
treat him my partner treated him
and were you there observing correct
and
can you tell me
what his
mental status was when
you were treating him
upon our assessment he was altered and
confused
in doing your assessment did you ask him
specific questions as to
what he what had happened on that day
yes
and what did he indicate to you in
response to those questions may i refer
to my report
all right let's have that mark please
that's your own copy man
just for the record we need to mark a
copy my apologies no no no no apology
necessary
just make sure that's the same document
that you have
d600-5
okay
can you rephrase the question
sure what would uh
what if anything do you recall michael
barrissone saying when you asked him
what had happened on that day
so per the report
do you um i apologize
uh yeah so for the report it did someone
drove down my driveway and said
she was going to take my kids that's all
i remember and quote
was he able to just describe or tell you
any events that occurred on that day
when asked
nothing else
did he say anything about his heart
yes there's a quote saying my heart
hurts but not physically unquote
did you have an opportunity to uh
observe the injuries uh on michael
barroso correct there's an indi a
detailed reportings of his injuries on
the report
can i show you d
856
[Music]
did he have an injury of his uh left arm
that you observed it was reported here
that
to his left upper arm findings pd
reported dockbite upon left upper
my apologies that's the thigh peter
reporter left forearm has deformity ice
pack and splint was applied prior to als
arrival multiple abrasions and punctured
wounds to the left arm how about his
left side his torso area
irrespective of what's in your report
did you observe
these injuries to his left side at any
point in time while you were treating
him not to my reflections okay
i'm sorry i didn't catch that answer
that's my reflection okay
just make sure you keep your voice up
man because our jurors in the gallery
have to hear
how about d
864
did you observe injuries
head findings or multiple hematomas on
both sides of his head does that
photograph accurately depict those
injuries
yes
how about 855
on this side of his face bruising noted
on the side of the base of left ear with
blood
and how about 852
the injuries uh on his face correct
version noted
now at some point in time
did you
have an impression slash diagnosis based
on your treatment
as paramedics we do not diagnose we
treat what we see and we were assessing
for the altered mental status okay and
what was your impression
he remained altered although we've ruled
out hypoglycemia via glucometer
i have nothing for you
cross-examination
you need this report here council
uh ms held you don't know specifically
when the defendant said someone drove
down my driveway and said she was going
to take my kids that's all i remember
you don't know if that's true
yeah you don't know if he did remember
or didn't remember that's what we were
told
no further questions judge thank you
all right you may step down miss help
thank you
do you have another witness this
afternoon mr blinkist
sure
defense calls
dr joseph a haney
all right dr joseph haney please
hi doctor
good afternoon please remain standing
for a minute you need to be sworn so uh
left hand on the bible raise your right
hand my core clerk will administer a
note
do you swing the presence of almighty
god that the testimony gives to this
court regarding this matter shall be the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth
yes please state your name as well your
last name for the record joseph heaty
h-e-i-n-e-y
thank you all right doctor you may have
a seat please keep your voice up
microphone uh does not project it only
records so okay we have to hear your
natural voice in the courtroom
if you don't understand the question
please don't answer it just indicate to
the court you're not sure you don't
understand and i'll have to counsel
rephrase all right go ahead mr belinkas
doctor where where are you
currently i'm employed at um new york
presbyterian brooklyn methodist hospital
um directing your attention back to
august of 2019 where were you employed
at morristown medical center
in what capacity um i was an emergency
physician in training resident physician
um on the trauma service
that day okay and uh
can you give the jury a little bit of
your background in regards to your
training
um
so
i
actually just completed training within
the last year three-year residency in
emergency medicine
um
you know before that was in medical
school um graduated school in 2018
graduated residency in 2021.
where did you go to school
new york medical college
in valhalla new york all right directing
your attention to august 7 2019
did
you have an opportunity to treat michael
barrasson
i did
that was at morristown medical center
correct
and and did you do an assessment uh
uh for your evaluation
yes what what physical uh
observations did you make of any
injuries to michael barrasso
so right off the bat we noted that i
believe his left elbow was deformed um
we could see that pretty clearly as he
came in
um
as we
did sort of our heads to assessment and
speaking to him
um
i i noticed there was the possibility of
blood behind his left eardrum it was it
was unclear it had that appearance
which worried us for a potential head
injury um and otherwise
otherwise as noted in the chart in terms
of physical injuries i don't recall much
else okay
i assume you've
seen a lot of people uh since then
correct
i'm going to show you
what's been marked into evidence
852.
does that accurately depict the injuries
that you saw on michael barriston's face
yes that that seems correct
how about my memory 855 does that
also act early to pick the injuries
yes
is and is that left ear the one you're
referring to
yes
864.
it seems correct
these are injuries to his
left side did you notice any injuries to
the left side of his body
uh if not if otherwise as i stated noted
in the chart um i don't recall at the
top of my head
how about 856 is
is that the uh
left arm that
you referred to as being deformed when
you first observed him yes
and
what was done to that left arm
so initially um we established that he
had good blood flow
past the injury of the elbow a good
pulse
we were still concerned for a
significant injury possibly to other
structures like nerves we attempted to
we obtained an x-ray and determined it
was dislocated
after which we attempted to reduce the
dislocation we did administer a sedative
medication to do that we were initially
not successful
and out of concern for
the potential head injury and other
injuries um
and the fact that the arm still had
circulation we elected to bring him to
ct scan to further assess for other
injuries and eventually once
we were able to establish everything
with this ct scan we're able to
relocate the arm with help of our
orthopedic colleagues right now
did you make note of his mental status
yes
and what was that
well when he came in he was responsive
he was answering my questions um
to a degree in obeying simple commands
one of the important things we assess
for things like squeeze my hand look
over here doing simple things like that
i did ask if he remembered the
you know what had happened uh prior to
arrival and he told me he didn't
remember
um
and
that was that's what i recall
was in a altered mental state
at any point
um
i'd say yes that's a that's a broad term
at the time we were
considering that that he was or
whether there was a physical or a
psychological component or both but yes
uh overall
nothing further
cross-examination
dr uh
do you still have that chart in front of
you
uh no um i'm sorry is this
no i don't think that i don't i think
that was some previous witness you have
this witnesses chart
thank you blind judge
just directing your attention at the
bottom right hand corner
and i'm not sure what that's marked i
apologize
uh but it should be on
uh the blue sticker at the top what's
that number
this one is d20 d20
doctor on the i'm not sure which page it
is in front of you but on mine it shows
up at
okay in the bottom right hand corner
um
i'm not seeing anything
mr shellhorn why don't you
show them where you wanna refer them to
please
that's that's my pj pg
so i'm going to direct you right here to
uh
the question about the
no acute intracranial hemorrhage or
significant mass effect can you explain
what that means to the jury
right so that was uh as i stated we
performed ct scans um
of his brain and other areas that's
referring to the scan of the brain
um one of the things the first thing we
look for is bleeding within the skull
either around the brain within the brain
um and the read from the radiologist
states there's no
bleeding for intracranial hemorrhage
there's no bleeding within the brain or
around the brain within the skull
or other
incidental findings such as the tumor
which would cause a mass effect so
there's nothing
grossly abnormal about within the skull
thank you very much doctor no further
questions church
all right any follow-up no all right you
may step down doctor thank you very much
for coming to court thank you
for today all right we'll break it's uh
4 20 or so
so members of the jury we're going to
break recess for the evening please
don't discuss the case with anyone we'll
see you tomorrow morning same time
we'll get going as close to nine o'clock
as we can so please get here around 8
30. thank you
[Music]
is
[Music]
all right just to blink this who's on
for tomorrow
[Music]
you